bienvenue à bibliothèque
missis
on refait ensemble la séance après les
questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat pour suivre l'examen du projet de
loi croissance et activité que vous
connaissez également sous le nom de
projet de loi Macron du nom du ministre
de l'économie les sénateurs en sont
toujours au deuxème volet du texte le
volet investir avec ce matin mesure qui
nous concern tous avec par exemple
l'amendement dit Google qui porte sur
les moteurs de recherche un amendement
qui veut garantir la neutralité
d'Internet et éviter l'abus de position
dominante de certains moteurs de
recherche Google pour ne pas le citer
l'amendement prévoit par exemple des
sanctions lorsque les moteurs de
recherche mettent en priorité leur lien
sur la page du moteur et des sanctions
qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 10 % du
chiffre d'affaires mondial du moteur de
recherche des sanctions relativement
inédites autre mesure qui devrait être
discuté ce matin les actions gratuites
pour intéresser les salariés et les
cadres dirigeants à l'augmentation de
valeur de leur entreprise voilà on
découvre ces mesures tout de suite dans
l'hémicycle alors je voulais dire que
toutes les zones ne ne seront pas
couvertes enfin d'après les les les avis
techniques que nous avons eu ça peut
être couvert par des paraboles Nous
avons déjà essayé effectivement dans
certains coins dans certains villages de
la commune avec des résultats qui sont
acceptables peut-être que la technique
pourra
s'améliorer en tout cas vous avez dit
monsieur le Premier ministre monsieur le
ministre que
et que vous auriez un guichet unique
avec
l'arcepte je souhaite également que au
niveau de la préfecture au niveau des
des que l'État reprenne un peu le
pouvoir dans les dép appartement et que
le préfet puisse aussi avoir un guichet
unique euh pour pouvoir suivre
cette l'avancée et les manques dans
cette couverture universelle
radiosensible
Radio Radio communication non non pas
Radi sensible parce que effectivement
dans notre secteur on a beaucoup de gens
qui sont pas radiosensibles et et qui
voudraient bien avoir cette couverture
donc je je souhaite également que les
préfectures soient impliquées dans ce
guichet unique pour suivre l'avancée de
de ce travail très très important pour
les zones rurales merci merci Monsieur
adnaud Merci monsieur le Président
j'avais prévu de poser cet après-midi
une question
d'actualité sur les problématiques qu'on
évoque en ce moment et puis je me disais
contenu du travail de la commission de
Monsieur reetaillot du gouvernement ça
ne va plus être nécessaire et bien ainsi
ça va être encore nécessaire parce que
je dois vous dire que tout ce que vous
avez dit ne me rassure en rien en rien
parce qu'il vous a fallu toutes ces
pages pour écrire en réalité que vos
cartes de vont concerner que les
centrebourg et que le problème qui nous
est posé ça n'est pas que les
centrebourg et je peux vous dire que si
demain vous allez dire que vous allez
solutionner le problème des zones
blanches en ayant traité que les
centrebourgs mais vous allez faire la
révolution dans les campagnes parce que
les gens n'en peuvent plus on parle
d'Internet mais ils nous disent mais on
a déjà même pas la téléphonie mobile et
je peux vous dire que moi j'ai demandé à
la totalité des commune de mon
département de faire une carte on leur a
fourni les éléments et ils ont pris les
téléphones avec les différents
abonnements et ils m'ont fait le
recensement de tous les points où il y a
rien et ben je peux vous dire c'est pas
170 communes et et c'est pas 170 zones
blanches et c'est pas 3600 zones grises
et donc le question qui va être posée
c'est la définition de ce qui est
concerné trois pages trois pages pour
nous dire une ligne ce n'est que le
centrebourg qui est concerné pour le
reste d'ailleurs un truc très
intéressant on peut lire qu'il va donc y
avoir un guichet couverture mobile pour
que les collectivités territoriales
puissent s'occuper des des zones
blanches hors centrebourg ça veut dire
encore une fois que l'aménagement du
territoire en France c'est à la charge
des collectivités dès qu'on n pas en
milieu urbain et ben moi je pense que il
faut qu'on vous le dise ça ne va pas
nous satisfaire je vais interroger le
Premier ministre C cet après-midi parce
que je vous garantis que si vous pensez
avoir un effet formidable en disant on
va résoudre le problème des zutes
blanches et je vais venir tous les 3
mois si c'est 3 mois sur la carte des
centrebourg c'est même pas la peine de
venir parce que c'est pas ça la question
c'est la totalité de la couverture et je
vous le dis tout de suite moi je suis
pas satisfait par aucun des amendements
qui sont proposés
là merci Monsieur
chaise monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors j'ai
écouté avec attention monsieur le
ministre vos explications et je voterai
bien sûr cet amendement néanmoins je
voudrais vous faire part de de plusieurs
commentaires notamment vous avez
monsieur le ministre pris un engagement
de venir devant les commissions pour
pouvoir vous expliquer et et faire un
état régulier de l'avancée de couverture
des des des zones néanmoins je suis
membre de la commission supérieure du
service public des postes et
communications électroniques et je suis
surpris de voir que cette Commission
n'ait pas été sollicitée pour avis de
votre proposition d'amendement qui est
un amendement important et et je
souhaiterais le dire ici ce matin alors
d'une façon générale je voudrais aussi
faire part de plusieurs réserves la
première serait que il me paraît utile
d'intégrer une notion de contrôle de
l'économie générale à savoir qu'il
serait dommageable que l'économie
générée par l'opérateur pour l'opérateur
ne soit pas totalement réinvesti sur le
réseau jeais aussi exprimer le fait que
il faudrait s'assurer que les
collectivités soient pas pris en otage
sur ces
opérations en leur imposant en leur en
pesant de faites des investissements
dont elle nurait pas normalement la
charge enfin vous avez abordé le sujet
de l'agence numérique euh c'est une
avancée intéressante je souhaiterais que
également on soit attentif à ce que
cette agence numérique ne devienne pas
une administration centrale loin des
élus et loin des dossiers concrets enfin
vous avez abordé aussi monsieur le
ministre le service universel il est
peut-être temps aujourd'hui de se poser
la question pour que ce service
universel soit possible sur la fibre
optique ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Moré
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues quelques
mots sur sur l'amendement du du du
gouvernement d'abord sur la forme
monsieur le ministre je trouve que nous
déposer un amendement technique et
complexe même la même la commission a
jugé que c'était difficile de d'en
mesurer la portée nous déposer un
amendement de 5 pages la veille du débat
et le remodifier le jour même du débat
c'est quand même vous en conviendraz pas
très satisfaisant monsieur le ministre
alors c'est vrai que le numérique mérite
peut-être mieux que ces amendements de
dernière minute j'ai entendu plusieurs
fois le président la commission spéciale
et la rapporteur dire qu'on essayit un
peu trop au détour de ce texte de régler
ou de de penser régler des problèmes et
et là vraiment je crois que c'est le cas
on a des amendements numériques qui sont
arrivés dans le projet de loi nôre on en
a qui arrivent dans ce projet de loi je
vous rappelle monsieur le ministre que
le Sénat a adopté en 2012 une
proposition de loi qui a été ensuite
rejetée purement et simplement à la
demande du gouvernement par l'Assemblée
nationale qui comportait des mesures
pour améliorer la couverture du
territoire en téléphonie mobile donc on
a perdu 3 ans pour aujourd'hui arriver à
cet amendement alors cet amendement bien
sûr il va dans le bon sens bien sûr que
c'est bien de de rouvrir le le dossier
de la couverture des zones blanches en
en 2G même si comme ça a été dit la 2G
aujourd'hui c'est très insuffisant mais
il y a des tas d'élus qui me disent
surtout lorsqu'ils entendent à la radio
la publicité pour la 4G ce qui a quand
même le don de les de les oripiler alors
qu'ils n'ont pas de 2g qu'il y a quand
même un véritable problème sur la 3G
vous mettez vous mettez dans la loi et
c'est très bien aussi vous mettez dans
votre amendement l'accord de r sharing
3G qui avait été signé en 2010 et qui
devait être réalisé pour 2013 et
aujourd'hui on est en 2015 à peine
un/art des engagements pris par les
opérateurs ont été tenus ce qui montre
bien monsieur le ministre comme vous
l'avez dit hier vous l' pas encore dit
aujourd'hui j'espère que ça n'était pas
une formule juste pour hier qu'il faut
mettre la pression sur les opérateurs
donc ce que vous proposez sur les
centrebourgs est bien mais mais comme
l'a dit comme l'a dit notre collègue
adenult il y a pas que les centrebourgs
il y a aussi toute la la partie rurale
et là sur la partie rurale il n'y a rien
de prévu si ce n'est de faire appel aux
collectivités pour financer évidemment
ça n'est pas quelque chose qui peut nous
donner entière satisfaction alors il y a
un certain nombre de question que moi
j'aimerais vous poser parce que j'ai pas
trouvé la réponse ni dans le texte
lui-même ni dans ce que vous nous avez
dit quelle sera exactement l'aide de
l'État parce qu'on nous parle de la
création d'un guichet mais comment ça va
fonctionner quelle sera le montant de
l'aide quel pourcentage par rapport au
projet tout ça on n sait rien quel sera
le financement des opérateurs on a bien
compris qu'il serait allégé d'un certain
nombre de charges avec la la suppression
des cabines téléphoniques et et c'est
très bien mais à quelle hauteur il il
ils participeront parce qu'en terme de
financement comme je l'ai dit la seule
chose dont on est sûr c'est que ce sont
les collectivités qui vont
financer le l'amendement du Gouvernement
parle de convention alors c'est un peu
complexe il y a des conventions entre
les opérateurs il y a semble-t-il je dis
bien semble-t-il une seule convention
entre les opérateurs l'État et les
collectivités mais j'aimerais que vous
précisiez les choses qu'est-ce qui se
passe si les opérateurs ne veulent pas
signer parce qu'on peut pas forcer une
partie à signer un opérateur est-ce
qu'on dit très clairement dans la loi
que les opérateurs auront l'obligation
d'aller sur ces équipements parce que je
signale monsieur le ministre
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des
collectivités qui sont dans une telle
situation qu'elles sont prêtes et j'ai
des exemples dans mon département elles
sont prête à financer une antenne pour
avoir la couverture en téléphonie mobile
et au moment de le faire l'opérateur
leur dire bah écoutez vous faites ce que
vous voulez nous de toute manière on
viendra pas sur votre antenne c'est
quand même un petit peu un petit peu
excessif donc est-ce que sur ce point-là
vous êtes prêt à mettre très clairement
les choses dans la loi vous parlez du
pouvoir de sanction de l'ARSEP monsieur
le ministre on sait très bien que l'arsp
elle-même le reconnaît euh elle est elle
a peu de d'aétence à sanctionner les
opérateurs je crois qu'elle ne l'a
jamais fait ou en tout cas très rarement
donc c'est bien de donner des poirs de
sanctions à l'ARCEP mais encore
faudrait-il qu'il soit utilisé quand
c'est nécessaire et on a un certain
nombre de cas qui montrre que ça aurait
été nécessaire je regrette aussi que
dans dans cet amendement euh on ne
revoit pas la question des critères de
couverture en téléphonie mobile parce
que ça aussi on a c'était dans le projet
dans la proposition de loi adopté par le
Sénat en 2012 ça a été dit par un
certain nombre d'intervenants ce matin
on sait très bien que le fait de
considérer comme couvert une commune dès
lors qu'il y a simplement un point
éventuellement en haut du clocher du
village qui est couvert ça n'est pas
satisfaisant et c'est ce qui donne ces
ces chiffres très flatteurs sur le taux
de couverture par rapport à la
population ou sur le nombre de communes
la réalité c'est que le nombre de
communes qui n'ont pas de couverture et
bien plus important qu'on nous dit moi
un jour j'ai découvert que aux yeux de
l'ARCEP aucun problème dans mon
département je vous invite à venir dans
l'heure monsieur le ministre vous verrez
que malheureusement ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas le cas donc voilà ce que je
voulais dire dans dans le temps qui
m'était imparti vous avez dit je
terminerai là-dessus qu'il y avait un
consensus monsieur le ministre je crois
qu'il y a un consensus sur le constat
mais qu'il faut sur ce sujet comme sur
bien d'autres d'ailleurs sortir des
constats sortir des des des des paroles
et passer comme nous l'avions dit déjà
en 2011 c'était le titre d'un rapport
sénatorial passer de la parole aux actes
merci Monsieur fouco
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre moi c'est sur le 1400
ceciétant je voulais donner mon avis sur
l'intervention de notre collègue
Philippe anneau qui était de plein de
bon sens si je vourais dire qu'on
partage son son sentiment alors pour
envenir au 1400 j'ai écouté madame la
rapporteur et et Monsieur le Ministre
moi je suis prêt à le
retirer mais faut-il encore sur le fond
le retirer et et le reformuler autrement
faut-il encore sur le fond accéder à la
demande de ce fond de compensation de de
TVA puisque lorsque les communes
investiss il est bien évident que on
leur rembourse le fond de compensation
de de de TVA parce queil s'agit pas de
verser comme hier soir des grosses
larmes sur les collectivités et puis le
lendemain de refuser des des amendements
qui vont justement dans le sens des
collectivités pour qu'ils puissent
récupérer un peu
d'argent un peu de celle qu'on leura
retiré d'ailleurs et en même temps
puisque nous voyons et là je me réfère
aux propos de notre collègue Hervé Moré
notamment ce qui
disait hier soir il y a d'un côté les
les opérateurs qui profitent les
collectivités malheureusement qui sont
en difficulté mais de la difficulté on
en rajoute à la difficulté lorsqu'ils
veulent faire des travaux et qu'on veut
pas compenser le fond le FC TVA bien sûr
madame la rapporteur heureusement qu'il
y a quelques subsides et subventions
mais ça ne suffit pas et vous le savez
très bien aux collectivités aujourd'hui
qui sont déjà d'ailleurs largement
pénalisés vu les baisses de dotations
des des collectivités et notamment de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement merci
Monsieur fouco monsieur
Colomba écoutez je crois que tout le
monde est convaincu que l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui succède notre collègue
va va dans le sens que nous souhait nous
souhaitons ceci
dit je voudrais quand même faire trois
remarques la première c'est que quand
même que de temps
oui non ça fait dans la plupart des
ville on est en 4G dans toutes
d'ailleurs et on n même pas terminé la
2G dans une partie des campagnes et je
souscris tout à fait au diagnostic de
mes de mes collègues précédment c'estàd
que on a même parfois l'impression en
tout cas chez moi c'est comme ça que ça
se dégrade bon et que effectivement les
estimations qui sont faites sont
parfaitement bidonnées ENF c'est que le
fait de toutes les de toutes les
statistiques c'est pas spécial c'est
c'est pas spécial et je ce qu'a dit
aussi notre collègue ad je je souscris
complètement on ne réglera pas le
problème si il y a pas une une
interprétation un peu extensive de cette
de cet amendement 2è 2è point ben oui
euh ce qui fche le plus
qui
paye qui paye alors là c'est un un flou
euh tout à fait impressionniste puisque
j'ai cru voir que comme d'habitude les
collectivités étaient chargé de faire
l'installation l'antenne d'amener
l'énergie enfin et cetera
euh on espère que les opérateurs
financeront les
réémetteurs enfin ça n'est pas euh ça
n'est pas euh certain alors
moi je j'avais une petite idée je me
suis toujours dit mais dans
cette pour que le service public appelé
aujourd'hui universel puisse atteindre
tous les coins de notre territoire
pourquoi ne pas généraliser la technique
de financement quit qui est mise en
place pour la Poste à travers un fond de
péréquation c'est-à-dire que les là on
prend un peu d'argent là où les
opérateurs en gagnent beaucoup pour
financer les opérations là où il n'en
gagnent pas parce qu'il nous aura
échapper à personne que le libéralisme
c'est très très bien là où on peut
gagner des sous mais où on peut pas
gagner des sous c'est quand même un peu
fâcheux ça marche pas bien ça marche pas
bien alors bon euh faire semblant de
croire que ça va se résoudre comme ça
sans poser le problème financier ça me
paraît euh ça me paraît pas euh pas tout
à fait sérieux et 3è 3ème point qui
rejoint un peu
celui-là dans les territoires ruraux qui
nous sommes un certain nombre à nous
intéresser plus particulièrement à à ces
territoires euh développer un réseau de
de communication performant concerne
effectivement les particuliers peut
concerner bien sûr les entreprises mais
aussi la sécurité civile et il serait
peut-être bon d'essayer de tout mettre
ça d' mettre la la la réflexion en
commun pour voir comment on peut mettre
en place des dispositifs qui permettront
de répondre à toutes ces à toutes ces
ces préoccupations or force de force de
constater que même ce qui existe n'est
pas utilisé de manière optimale Hervé
Moret a rappelé le problème qu'il qu'il
rencontre moi je pourrais vous en citer
un autre c'est pas la téléphonie mobile
mais c'est effectivement l'utilisation
des investissements qui ont été faits en
matière de de fibre où Orange se refuse
à se refuse à apporter enfin à délivrer
le service télévision à un endroit où
les communes ont fait l'investissement
en fibre optique alors il paraît qu'il y
a une obscure raison législative j'en
sais rien mais voilà voilà où nous en
sommes donc monsieur le ministre si on
pouvait mettre un peu tout ça à plat et
sortir de la technique qui consiste à
de temps en temps prendre des mesures
ici ou là et en espérant que la main de
Dieu ou du marché finira pour régler par
régler le problème je crois qu'on on
pourrait on pourrait progresser d'autant
que quand on regarde bien ça coûte pas
des sommes
extraordinaires mais il faut s'y prendre
peut-être
autrement monsieur
requier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur mes chers collègues d'abord je
voterai l'amendement du Gouvernement
parce qu'il va dans la bonne direction
et puis je salue donc le l'engagement de
Monsieur le Ministre deevenenir tous les
3 mois devant la commission compétente
en matière de financement moi je pense
que si on regarde un peu en histoire si
on regarde l'électricité l'électricité
avait été développé dans par les grandes
compagnies dans les centres urbains et
comme les campagnes é abandonné on a
créé les syndicats intercommunaux et
pour les financer on a créé en 1936 le
fassé le fond d'emortissement des
charges d'électrification qui existe
encore qui consiste à prendre davantage
dans les communes urbaines que rurales
pour donc équiper les communes rurales
je trouve c'est un bon système et
n'oublons pas que contrairement à la
téléphonie les lignes électriques
appartiennent aux collectivité ce qui
est une bonne chose je vrais répondre
simplement à Monsieur de César je crois
qu'il est parti ce son l'amendement j'ai
pas pu le faire tout à l'heure sur je
lui propose pour les zones vous saz
blanchees qui qui voudrait rester
blanche je lui propose de faire un appel
à projet savoir quelles sont les zones
qui veulent rester s téléphone mobile et
bien écoutez on verra on verra le
résultat à moins que peut-être à moins
peut-être que quelqu quartier du mar du
6e ou du 8e soit candidat à
l'expérimentation merci
monsur la parole est à Monsieur Roch
oui merci de me donner la parole je vais
voter cet amendement avec le même
enthousiasme qu'un médecin mais un
cataplasme sur une jambe de bois
je vais faire part moi d'une grosse
déception et d'une grande colère alors
la déception elle porte sur la
téléphonie mobile je vais prendre comme
exemple mon département le département
de la Haute Loire mais je crois que
c'est transposable dans toutes les zones
rurales nous avons fait trois plans
d'installation de la téléphonie mobile
qui ont très bien marché avec
l'itinérance entre les opérateurs et
depuis que l'on a fait ça ben qu'est-ce
qu'on voit c'est que le service chaque
année de mois en mois se
dégrade on on a l'arrêt de la téléphonie
mobile fonctionne beaucoup moins bien
qu'il y a euh 2 ou 3 ans moi j'avais SFR
j'ai dit ben SF ils mettent la 4G ils
ont des ennuis je vais aller chez Orange
et l'orange est très amer elle marche
pas plus que
SFR le service se dégrade nous avons mis
de l'argent nous avons installé les poau
nous avons passé les les contventions de
d'itinérance avec les opérateurs la
téléphile ne marche pas et le pire c'est
que les gens quand ils vont se plainre
chez Orange ù c'est les opérateurs on
leur dit allez voir le Conseil général
c'est lui qui avait monté le projet
alors non seulement on est cocu entre
guillemets mais on se fait attraper par
derrière ça c'est la
déception mais la colère est bien pire
la colère est pire elle touche le Très
Haut Débit nous avons monté un ha Loir
une opération très haut débit pour
arriver à 100 100
Mabit soit par la fibre soit par le wifi
soit par les le satellite on a monté ça
avec le Cantal l'Allier les qu le pu
d'OM les quatre départements et la
région et ça a très bien marché nous
avons Moné un très beau projet et nous
sommes très
mais pour monter ce projet j'ai engagé à
l'époque où j'étais comme président de
conseil général le conseill général
touloir 20 € par habitant et par an
pendant 25
ans j'espère qu'on va réussir ça marche
mais comment expliquer aux gens que les
opérateurs vont sur les grandes
agglomérations là où il y a de de une
bonne rentabilité ils s'en mettent plein
les poches et puis on laisse la ruralité
se débrouiller pour pouvoir s'installer
pour avoir cette autoroute quand même du
21e siècle pour le développement de la
ruralité et bien on nous laisse seul
c'est du service public où est la
République française comment peut-on
accepter de défendre le service public
c'est une si on accepte que le la la
ruralité n'est pas les moyens de
s'équiper de ce qui est essentiel pour
avir des nouveaux actifs et pour sauver
la ruralité c'est pas un dossier annexe
c'est un dossier essentiel pour sauver
la ruralité et nous sommes complètement
en dehors du service public alors en
plus il y a un corollaire c'est
qu'allons nous demander pourquoi notre
ruralité se réfugie dans des votes
protestataires lorsqu'il y a des
élections et bien ce sont avec des
choses comme ça qu'on le fait nous
sommes dans service public et le service
public est actuellement bafoué pour
l'installation du triut débit merci
Monsieur Roch la parole est à Madame
BRI oui moi je voudrais remercier le
président rill qui a retiré son
amendement la rapporteur madame la
rapporteur qui a émis un avis de sagesse
sur l'amendement du Gouvernement mais
j'écoute tous ceux qui disent c'est il
faut plus il y a des problèmes et
techniques et financiers mais je
voudrais quand même leur rappeler deux
choses que c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement
s'engage vraiment pour nous l'avons dit
toute la nuit mettre la pression sur les
opérateurs ver c'est oui mais le
ministre
le ministre vient de
s'engager il vient de
s'engager à venir devant les commission
compétente avec une carte l'avancée des
travaux et Madame la rapporteur a posé
fort justement une question concernant
les coûts et je pense que le ministre
aussi il fera attention notamment pour
les 170 communes qui ont besoin de la
couverture de de au niveau de la 2G il a
pris un engagement aussi qui consiste à
ce que ce soit fait à la fin de l'année
2016 madame la rapporteur vous avez dit
c'est un vrai défi et moi je fais
confiance au gouvernement c'est la
première fois que l'État s'engage il
faut que l'État soutienne les
collectivités puis la deuxième
observation que je veux faire c'est
qu'on sort d'une campagne départementale
hein c'est encore tout frais
et dans vos départements vous vous êtes
tous engagés
dans la campagne je parle notamment au
présidents de conseil généraux sortant
ou ceux qui sont n'ont pas été sortis
mais même ceux qui ont été sortis tout
le monde s'est engagé à ce qu'il ait
cette couverture des zones blanches donc
on a un intérêt commun état collectivité
locale et territoriale parce que pour ce
qui concerne ma région î-de-france la
région aussi est engagé au côté de mon
département de saine etmarne donc ce que
je veux dire c'est que franchement il
faut voter plutôt de bon cœur en toute
confiance l'amendement du Gouvernement
il va faire avancer la cause des
collectivités qu'on défend par ailleurs
et je moi je suis sûr qu'il y aura une
pression très forte sur les opérateurs
dont on connaît la difficulté à
dépasser les les Bours comme vous dites
merci Madame BRI la parole est à
Monsieur
gremiller oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les
rapporteurs j'ai vraiment l'impression
que on a un débat à un moment où quelque
part on n'est pas quand même très fort
par rapport à ce qui a été capable ce
qu'on était capable de réaliser dans
notre pays quand je vois cette
lumière la capacité qu'on a eu diriguer
l'ensemble de nos territoires l'ensemble
de nos territoires
on est en train d'examiner ce projet de
loi sur la croissance monsieur le
ministre le développement économique
l'égalité des chances
économiques c'est sûr que l'amendement
du Gouvernement c'est une avancée mais
je vis dire à notre collègue madame BRI
je suis désolé quand on va présenter ça
au président comme vous venez de le dire
des départements aujourd'hui et qu'on
dit qu'on va se limiter au centrebourg
nous avons tous dans nos départements
regardons réellement ce qui se passe des
entreprises qui par définition ne sont
pas au centrebourg et qui sont
complètement éliminés éliminés et qui
aujourd'hui dans les départements ruraux
on a tous des exemples de délocalisation
d'entreprise parce qu'aujourd'hui elles
n'ont pas effectivement la téléphonie et
internet deuxè exemple que je vrais
donner monsieur le
ministre la plupart des actes
administratifs combien aujourd'hui qui
répondent à des appels d'offre ils ne
peuvent le faire aujourd'hui que par
Internet s'il n'ont pas cette couverture
effectivement ils sont exclus de cette
croissance donc il est absolument
nécessaire d'aller plus loin que cette
irrigation limité au centrebourg et de
regarder l'activité rurale qui se
déroule sur nos territoires et ça se
limite pas au centrebourg et ça se
limite pas au rassemblement des
centrebourgs oui bien sûr à condition
qu'on le dise à condition qu'on le
précise on ne peut pas et qu'on le fasse
effectivement on ne peut pas piéger de
cette manière autant d'activités
économique réparti sur nos territoire
c'est pour ça que je souhaite des
engagements complémentaires de la part
de Monsieur le Ministre à cet instant
pour aller plus loin sur cet amendement
sinon effectivement il est pas
satisfaisant merci Monsieur B
ou merci monsieur le Président j'étais
cignataire de la amendement de Bruno
rotillot parce que je pensais que
c'était très important et puis là dans
cet amendement on parlait bien sûr de
les des zones non couvertes en service
de radio commmunication des zones non
couvertes alors c'est vrai que j'ai fait
2 ans un rapport avec notre collègue
niikou qui maintenant n'est plus parmi
nous mais sur l'avenir des campagnes et
toutes toutes les auditions qu'on a
faites et bien les gens sont tous
revenus sur l'avenir des campagnes
c'était déjà bien entendu les
communications et puis bien sûr en
téléphonie mais aussi en haut débit vous
le pensez bien alors
aujourd'hui je regrette finalement que
notre collègue Bruno rotaillot a retiré
son amendement il s'en va parce que
quand même il y avait quand même une
chose de très très différente de celui
que nous propose le ministre et Daniel
gremiller vient de le dire parce que
Monsieur le le ministre nous dit euh les
centrebourgs des communes on a parlé de
mais il y a combien de communes je vois
même dans mon département où il y a pas
le quart des habitants qui habitent au
centrebourg qui a 60 àau je peux vous
citer chapelle volant je peux vous citer
l chaois c'est des communes de 1000
habitants mais où il y a 700 habitants
qui nabite pas au centrebourg et bien
ces pauvres là ils vont être déçus si on
vote un tel amendement et moi j'ai un
cas de conscience à instant est-ce que
je ne peux voter que pour les
centrebourgs c'est pour ça que Madame r
je vais vous décevoir mais moi je vais
pas voter cet amendement s'il ne
signifie que les centrebourgs que les
centrebourgs parce qu'on abandonne
encore là des pans entiers de notre
ruralité où il y a comme Daniel
Gremillet vient de le dire il y a des
exploitations agricoles aussi où la
dématérialisation elle est là mais on
parle de téléphonie portable à cette
instant mais ce sera la même chose pour
les haut débit et puis encore aussi de
demander encore à ses collectivités de
mettre la main à la poche alors que des
communes souvent bien entendu beaucoup
plus riches on leura rien demandé pour
justement toutes ces sujets là alors là
aussi il y a quand même une différence
très importante c'est encore souvent C
ces secteurs qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
ressources encore on leur demande si
vous voulez les équipements il faut
mettre la main à la poche donc cet
amendement moi je ne vais pas le voter
je vous dis tout de suite ou alors il
faut que monsieur le ministre vous
repreniez ce qui était dit dans notre
amendement avec qu'on avait signé avec
Monsieur rotillot et bien on on on parle
des zones non couvertes à ce moment-là
je vote l'amendement je crois que c'est
très très important et très capital
chers collègues et Monsieur Montauger
ou monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers chers collègues voilà moi
je je je je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
rejeter un un amendement fut-il issu du
gouvernement qui constitue un réel
progrès et et la reconnaissance d'une
d'une situation territoriale en matière
dans les zones rurales problématiqu
c'est le c'est c'est le premier point il
y a une prise de conscience de la part
du du du gouvernement sur sur ce sujet
relayé par l'ensemble des des des des
élus qu'il soit de droite ou ou de
gauche ou d'ailleurs voilà donc
personnellement je je je voterai cet
amendement sans sans aucune difficulté
il ne règle pas tout mais il constitue
un un progrès certain sur la question du
financement monsieur Ruquier m'a m'a
enlevé si j'ose dire la l'argument que
je vous ai je voulais développer par
rapport au fassé effectivement en
matière d'élect cité et d'électricité
rurale euh le le fassé constitue un un
bon exemple et je pense qu'il faudrait
travailler cette cette piste pour
effectivement
euh accélérer la la la la question si ce
n'est résoudre la question du du du
financement de la téléphonie mobile et
même et même du du très haut débit
numérique euh au-delà de ça la question
qui est posée c'est celle de la
fiscalité également euh de de tout ce
qui est lié à la fois la téléphonie
mobile et au très haut débit et la
fiscalité euh assise sur le
développement d'une nouvelle économie
l'économie du numérique je pense que ce
cette question là elle est devant nous
elle doit être elle doit être traitée
elle est tout à fait considérable quant
à la manière dont
notre pays doit se réorganiser par
rapport à l'émergence de cette nouvelle
économie et dernier dernière remarque
elle touche à l'aspect technique si ce
n'est technologique du du sujet il
m'arrive parfois de m'interroger euh sur
sur la question effectivement des coûts
tout à fait considérables nécessaires au
développement des réseaux filaires du du
très haut débit en particulier on sait
qu'en même temps que que la fibre
optique peut être une solution presque
idéale à la question du du transport des
des des Très Haut Débit euh se
développent aussi en parallèle des
techniques satellitaires et autres qui à
terme seront peut-être tout aussi
performantes et à des coûts probablement
bien moindr il y a une vraie question
par rapport à ça est-ce que est-ce que
les les sommes l'argent public qui va
être dépensé pour développer ces réseaux
ne risqueil pas d'être voilà
reconsidérer dans quelques années dans
quelques années c'est une c'est une
vraie question qui pose qui pose le le
sujet de
l'efficience et de l'efficacité donc des
des sommes P qui pourrai être engagé par
rapport par rapport à cette ce sujet là
voilà Monsieur
Touren
ou je
veux je veux regretter que vous n'ayez
pas manifester cette
véhémence cette passion cet
attachement au secteur rural lorsque
vous étiez au pouvoir et lorsque
Monsieur Sarko confiait aux organismes
privés le soin de desservir les secteurs
les plus rentable en oubliant
complètement le monde
rural si nous en sommes là aujourd'hui
si nous sommes amenés à payer les
erreurs du passé c'est bien parce que
vous manifestez cette virginité que vaut
l'opposition vous avez oublié parce que
la mémoire est volatile et sûrement la
vôtre que vous êtes à l'origine du péché
originel qui nous place dans cette
situation et pour une fois qu'un
gouvernement fait les efforts
nécessaires c'est là que l'appétit vous
vient et que vous réclamer encore
davantage alors tout de même un peu
d'humilité un peu de modestie et un peu
de souvenir merci Monsieur Touren madame
linman allez elle va intervention de mon
collègue va raccourcir mon intervention
parce que en réalité vous passez votre
temps à nous parler concurrence
concurrence privatisation libéralisation
et quand vous le faites évidemment vous
constatez une chose simple vous donnez
au privés les secteurs rentables la le
secteur urbain et encore tous les
secteurs urbains ne sont pas toujours
bien desservis et vous constatez
qu'ensuite dans les secteurs moins
rentables notamment un certain nombre de
zones rurales et ben là bonjour il
faudrait que l'intervention publique
arrive en en pompier c'est cette vision
qui ne peut pas tenir elle peut pas
tenir pour plusieurs raisons vous avez
accepté des directives européennes sans
exiger des directives CAD de service
d'intérêt général et d'ailleurs je
souhaite monsieur le ministre que le
gouvernement français reprenne
l'initiative d'obtenir en matière de
réseau et en matière de ce que nous
appelons en France les services publics
une directive 4 par secteur fixant les
cadres du service d'intérêt général car
dans certains cas il faut non dans
certains cas il faut des compensations
financières il faut des
compensations de droit à à des aides
publiques qui ne sont pas actuellement
dans le loi la loi communautaire mais je
voudrais plaider monsieur le ministre en
j'approuve votre détermination que vous
avez exprimé hier de peser sur les
opérateurs le gouvernement doit se faire
entendre et il doit se faire entendre en
s'en donnant les moyens et j'approuve
aussi le fait que vous ayez constaté que
le fait d'avoir du capital public dans
les entreprises est une façon d'avoir du
pouvoir puisque vous débattez de ce
sujet avec l'entreprise Renault
aujourd'hui donc en tout cas ces sujets
j'approuve cette démarche mais il se
trouve que les gouvernements passent et
que les opérateurs restent et qu'il faut
donc trouver des moyens d'intervention
qui soient agravés dans la loi et en
particulier des moyens financier et moi
j'approuve les propositions de nos
collègues Colomba de constituer un fond
de péréquation qui soit de nature à
permettre au moins qu'on ait des outils
pour compenser les zones qui ne sont pas
couvertes et donc j'approuve cette
démarche que je trouve efficace et
probablement pour l'URE l'une des rares
compatibles avec les règles
européennes merci madamean monsieur
Guillaume
oui monsieur
le président exactement monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais prendre ma part à la
prise de parole de tous les sénateurs
mais je constate si je peux me permettre
que la réforme du règlement voulu par le
président du Sénat et accompagné par
tous les groupes sera une bonne chose
parce qu'il reste 900 amendements et
faud quand même que nous organisions
différemment mais je prends ma part à à
la à la discussion profitons
exactement pour dire deux trois choses
simples d'abord d'abord quel que soi les
sénateurs et les sénatrices sur tous les
bancs nous avons la même orientation la
même volonté celle de la couverture
mobile de nos territoires et celle de la
couverture numérique de nos territoires
et de tous les territoires pas que les
villes pas que les métropoles là où il
pleut là où il pleut toujours où c'est
mouillé comme disait ma grand-mère parce
que là il y a pas de problème lorsque
l'on regarde par le passé les zones amis
où c'était c'était dans les villes et
lorsque l'on sortait légèrement des
villes il n'y avait plus rien et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé toutes les
collectivités locales les aglos et
notamment les conseils généraux qui ont
fait un travail remarquable et s'il
avait été là j'aurais voulu saluer Bruno
retaillot ce qu'il a fait dans son
département qui est certes un
département plat sans montagne donc un
peu plus simple mais l'engagement qu'il
a eu pendant toutes ces années
le seul le seul un des très rares dans
notre hémicycle qui a dit j'ai des
choses fortes et qu' l'a écrit c'est
Hervé Moré et je veux lui rendre hommage
avec d'autres et nous l'avons suivi et
il a dit il y a quelques années en
arrière que la façon dont on nous
présentait le sujet de la couverture
numérique du territoire ne collait pas
parce que nous avons tous été favorbl à
la création du STR du schéma du du
schéma national d'aménagement numérique
du territoire mais quand le fond d'amén
numérique du territoire a été créé il y
avait 0 € et donc nous n'avons pas été
capable l'État n'a pas été capable de
nous accompagner qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé toutes les collectivités locaux
locales notamment les départements
beaucoup de présidents de conseil
généraux sont exprimés Bruno sidau hier
qui étit un des premiers dans son
département a avancé qui a fait un gros
gros travail là-dessus comme nous avons
pu le faire ailleurs nous avons pris nos
responsabilités et nous avons avancer et
parce que les opérateurs ne finançaient
rien et bien ce sont les collectivités
locales et les départements qui ont payé
des poteaux pour la téléphonie mobile
qui on fait des réseaux publics de fibre
optique qui sont du patrimoine
départemental comme les routes
départemental comme
l'électricité la fibre optique est
devenu un patrimoine départemental et
nous continuerons madame brick l'a dit
tout à l'heure dans toutes la les
campagnes des départementales récentes
dans tous les départements tous les
candidats de droite comme de gauche et y
compris les nouveaux présidents de
droite qui ont été élus très nombreux
ont dans leur programme nous voulons une
couverture numérique du territoire forte
et notamment
nous voulons que la ruralité
soit est une réponse mais nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup avancé déjà et dans
toutes les discussions que nous avons
déjà aujourd'hui la plupart des Bours
ont déjà ont déjà de de la fibre ont
déjà du ha débit le problème c'est la
ruralité c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut faire j'allais dire c'est pas
la politique des petits pas mais
l'amendement du
Gouvernement ça suffit peut-être pas
évidemment pour ce qu'on veut tous nous
mais c'est quand même une avancée
si déjà là où c'est pas fait dans mon
département tous les centrebourg sans
aucune exception ont la fibre optique
toutes les zones d'activité les 135
zones artisanales et d'activité ont la
fibre optique mais a des endroits on
n'est pas allé assez loin et
l'amendement du Gouvernement va dans le
bon sens et moi je vous engage vraiment
mes chers collègues à le voter parce que
là au moins on aura pour la première
fois un cadre alors tout à l'heurev Moré
dit oui mais est-ce que c'est des
intentions on va voir pour l'instant non
mais pour l'instant il avit pas
avme pas d'attion donc pour l'instant il
y a des
intentions est-ce que c'est trop long
sûrement mais il faut voter l'amendement
du Gouvernement qui va nous donner une
visibilité et puis moi je fais confiance
à tous les sénateurs à tous les élus
locaux pour aller plus loin par que
quand monsieur btholone dans son rapport
remis au Président de la République dit
je voudrais que les éarques aillent dans
les villes c'est peut-être une bonne
chose mais moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
qu'ils aillent en zone rurale qu' se
rendent compte de la vie ou là où les
services publics ont disparu là où l'on
souffre là où il y a pas d'éducateur là
où c'est difficile et là il verrait
aussi qu'en dehors des grandes villes et
du périphérique il y a une vie intense
et donc notre engagement c'est
évidemment me semble-t-il de soutenir la
cette amendement du gouvernement parce
que c'est un pas en avant mais de ne
rien lâcher pour la suite de ne rien
lâcher pour la suite parce que ce qui
sera très important c'est de permettre
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
dans toutes les zones rurales retisser
le lien entre le citoyen et la
République c'est pas uniquement ça mais
c'est que le citoyen il est accès à tous
les services publics à toutes les
informations et qu'il se sentent pas
déclassé et défavorisé par rapport à
d'autres et le numérique n'est pas la
seule réponse mais c'est une des
réponses c'est pour ça que monsieur le
Président que je pense que nous devons
voter cet amendement qui est une avancée
mais si nous nous arrêtions là nous
faillirons à notre mission merci
monsieur Guillaume monsieur
grand
de de principe j'ai observé que notre
collègue sétonné qu' nous soyons
nombreux à nous exprimer lui-même s'est
exprimé au-delà de son temps je voudrais
simplement dire que c'est pas la faute
du Parlement si les choses sont lentes
je pense que c'est l'honneur du
Parlement c'est l'honneur de cette
assemblée de pouvoir s'exprimer voyez
comment ça se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale et je vous parle par
expérience et bien c'est un non débat
ici c'est un vrai débat ici nos
électeurs et nos électrices on le
sentiment d'être défendu dans
l'hémicycle sur ce sujet chers collègues
et chers collègues au pluriel sur ce
sujet nous avons tous été interpellés
par tous les maires lors des élections
sénatoriales et donc aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre nous parlons en
leur nom pas au nôtre pas pour se faire
plaisir pas pour avoir au Journal
officiel notre nom je comprends que les
rapporteurs soit un peu fatigué enassz
l'entend toujours abâcher la même chose
mais je dis qu'aujourd'hui l'honneur du
Parlement c'est de pouvoir s'exprimer
donc je mets en garde quand même
ce cette habitude un peu de vouloir
aujourd'hui nous couper le temps de
parole le ramener comme à l'Assemblée
nationale moyen en quoi moyen en quoi
chers collègues je vous le dis et je
vous le dis par expérience un député
aujourd'hui ça compte pour zéro un
sénateur c'est respecté donc modifier le
règlement dans le sens de nous ne plus
nous permettre de débattre et vous
verrez combien et vous verrez combien le
Sénat sera rabaissé
laiss terminer l'orateur simplement
simplement non mais je voudrais le dire
parce que ça bon voilà je je pense qu'
il faut qu'on arrête de de de de voter
des textes de prendre des décisions qui
vont qui sont contraires à l'intérêt de
notre mission je je voudrais très très
rapidement monsieur le ministre
concernant donc la la couverture mobile
numérique vous dire que effectivement
moi je me sens aujourd'hui le devoir de
prendre la parole parce que les 360
maires de mon département et je suis
l'un d'entre eux souhaite que
effectivement cette couverture soit soit
soit soit rapidement mise en œuvre alors
moi je m'inquiète parce que j'observe
effectivement des grandes fusions et la
seule solution que je trouve parce que
moi dans ma commune elle va être fini
d'être totalement couverte hein
totalement couverte mais je suis gêné
par rapport à mes autres collègues des
haut canton qui eux ont de l'industrie
et compris touristique hein ou dans
l'hôtel il faut utiliser le téléphone
habituel parce qu'il y a rien qui passe
bon donc que je voudrais vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre qu'il faut trouver
une solution moi la solution parce que
je vois le danger de ces de ces fusions
qui sont en train et demain quel pouvoir
on va avoir quel pouvoir aura le
gouvernement nous on en aura pas et vous
peut-être encore moins moins que nous
donc peut-être qu'il faudrait prendre
une décision c'est de de faire en sorte
que quand nos zones urbaines à nous sont
couvertes et bien qu' a une certaine
égalité de traitement automatique
c'est-à-dire que si on on ne on couvre
pas d'autres zones et bien il y a pas de
marchés qui sont passés dans nos zones
urbaines certes c'est nous qui ferons un
effort mais comme les zones rurales et
les zones non couvertes le font depuis
très longtemps je pense que ça
répondrait quand même à à une attente
que ça répond à l'attente de nos élus et
dans tous les cas c'est une forme de
respect voilà un sujet de réflexion
alors sous quelle forme peut-on le faire
je n'en sais rien c'est à vous de le de
proposer mais moi je trouve que c'est
scandaleux de voir que les les les les
opérateurs déploi chez nous hein déploie
chez nous dans nos zones urbaines hein
pourquoi parce que c'est rentable ils le
disent ils s'enachent Pasin je veux dire
ils vous le disent hein et puis dans les
zones où c'est pas rentable et bien on
reste l'arme au pied donc il faut
absolument que désormais hein il y ait
un lien entre les deux zones celles qui
sont
localement qui qui localement vont être
couvertes et celles qui ne peuvent pas
l'être voilà on vous voulez pas le faire
dans le rural et ben vous le ferez vous
mettrez plus de temps dans l'urbain
merci merci merci Monsieur mard vous
avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez eu raison
de déposer ce projet de loi parce que ça
nous permet de vous avoir sous la main
durablement et nous y éprouvons un tel
plaisir que je pense que nous allons
faire le maximum pour prolonger ces
grands moments de concertation parce que
B au moins au moins ça vous permet
d'entendre
le cri de nos territoires ruraux vous ne
pourrez pas sortir de cette enceinte
sans vous être sans avoir été convaincu
qu'il y a un réel problème je vous
l'avais exposé mais là au moins vous
avez un concert général quant à la
responsabilité de cette situation j'ai
entendu parler du gouvernement de droite
du gouvernement de gauche pour moi la
responsabilité elle est équitablement
partagée entre les gouvernements qui se
sont succédés pour nous abandonner
alors ce problème des zones rurales il
ne concerne d'ailleurs pas que la
téléphonie mobile il faut que vous
sachiez monsieur le ministre que pour le
téléphone fixe il nous arrive à nous
dans nos communes moi j'habite dans une
petite commune à 15 km du centre de
l'agglomération il nous arrive et je
sais que dans le département voisin du
lre j'ai pu en faire
l'expérimentation je le dis à mon ami
Jean-Claude requier pour pour le le
dépannage de la téléphonie fixe il nous
arrive d'attendre plusieurs
semaines voir plus d'un mois et quand
vous avez des gens qui habitent dans des
dans des hameau qui n'ont pas d'ailleurs
la téléphonie mobile mais il faut se
rendre compte qu'on on on c'est un
retour en arrière c'est ça la réalité y
compris celle
d'Orange sachez-le parce que c'est la
vérité de deuxièmement c'est pas parce
qu'il y a eu la création d'une autorité
indépendante comme l'arcepep que ça a
permis de solutionner les problèmes oui
monsieur le Président Guillaume les
autorités indépendantes vous voulez nous
en rajouter d'autres leur donner encore
plus de pouvoir et bien regardez ce que
ça donne bon alors votre oui elles sont
indépendantes sauf d'elles-même bon mais
c'est pas la solution la solution c'est
que l'État assume son rôle assume ses
responsabilités trè
observation dans cet excellent
amendement d'ailleurs nous allons le
voter nous allons le voter parce que
c'est un progrès bon et et et déjà rien
que ça pour une fois que ça va pas
harculon on va pas vous dire que c'est
pas bien bon mais dans cette amendement
vous dites que l'État les représentants
des collectivitésales territoriales les
opérateurs de communication électronique
hein vont intervenir ensemble dans un
délai de 3 mois et et vous dites que
cette convention qui va être conclu elle
prévoit notamment les conditions dans
lesquelles les collectivités
territoriales et leur groupement peuvent
intervenir d'abord je voulais quand même
rappeler à un certain nombre de nos
collègues que le rôle des départements
ces départements que d'aucun voulait
supprimer il y a quelques mois je ne
l'entends plus parce que on on voit on
voit l'importance qu'ils ont pour
essayer de solutionner ces problèmes
c'est une réalité bon mais mais ça ça
pose un une autre question monsieur le
ministre c'est celle des compétences
parce que on nous a dit rabâé qu'il
fallait hein que les choses soient
claires au niveau des compétences
clarification des compétences mais là
j'ai j'ai j'ai pas trop compris en ce
qui concerne ce type de
problème s'il y a un problème de
compétence à trancher ou si vous
considérez que tout le monde doit mettre
la main à la poche parce que quand il y
a de ce type de difficulté bah on fait
abstraction des grands en principe et je
crois que ce qu'il faut c'est trouver
des solutions concrètes en tout cas le
problème il existe il n'a pas été réglé
et non seulement il n'a pas été réglé
mais il s'est aggravé ces dernières
années et nous avons pu vivre pour
certains d'entre nous je donne un
exemple concret le passage du Sénat de
SFR à Orange pour certains ça a été
mieux pour d'autres c'est la coupure des
communications sans
commenter Monsieur
R
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègu quelques mots
simplement monsieur le ministre vous
avez pu comprendre que sur l'ensemble
des bans de cet hémicycle il y avait une
volonté commune que puisse être mis en
place dans ce souci d'équité
d'efficacité de
permettre de donner à tous les mêmes
moyens économiques de d'assurer la
couverture de l'ensemble du territoire
je dis bien l'ensemble du territoire et
notamment bien sûr en particulier à la
ruralité alors vous savez l'avantage que
dans le travail que nous faisons ici
c'est qu'il nous arrive après une grande
discussion de modifier quelque peu un
texte si bien entendu les gens il sont
en sont d'accord mais je vous fais une
proposition simple et ça va régler le
problème pour tout le monde et je pense
que
votreant sera adopté à l'unanimité c'est
de substituer à votre première alinéa
qui att tra au centrebourg le premier
paragraphe
de l'amendement de Monsieur rillot et là
vous allez répondre à toutes les
attentes qui ont été largement manifesté
sur ce territoire et je pense que si ça
vous acceptiez ça et ce serait pas une
nouveauté que de le faire parce que nous
le faisons régulièrement et bien vous
donneriez satisfaction à tout le monde
même si ça doit se faire progressivement
mais vous donneriez satisfaction à tout
le monde donc je suggère et je propose
que vous substituiez à premier alinéat
qui dit les centrebourgs de communes qui
répondent au critères fixés au premier
alinéat du du même TR le premier
paragraphe de l'amendement de Monsieur
retaillot ça allongera pas beaucoup
puisqu'il y a 5inq lignes votre texte
mais ça permettra de donner satisfaction
à tout le
monde merci Monsieur revet madame
douanau monsieur président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues c'est vrai que
le débat que nous avons ce matin est en
résonance avec celui que nous avons
entendu depuis des années sur nos
territoires et je voudrais vous rappeler
alors monsieur le ministre c'est sans
doute un peu trop tôt pour vous mais en
1960 quand Fernand Renaud avait écrit
son fameux sketch le 22 à agère vous
n'étiez pas né monsieur le ministre et
bien la moitié des Français attendait la
tonalité alors que l'autre moitié
attendait le téléphone au
aujourd'hui nous parlons de la 4G sur
certains territoires alors que certains
attendent la 2G et qu'ils ne l'auront
peut-être pas tout de suite et puis
certains parlent du très haut débit
quand d'autres n'ont pas encore la
téléphonie mobile alors voilà c'est un
cri de douleur c'est un cri qui
finalement nous amène à à prendre nos
responsabilités et je voudrais dire
combien finalement nous sommes
coresponsables de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je crois
qu'il ne faut pas non plus se heurter
les uns aux autres le monde rural a
besoin de ses équipements euh il appelle
à à notre conscience et je crois que
Monsieur le Ministre même si voilà vous
avez peut-être pas pu proposer ces
efforts là plus tôt et bien moi je vous
suivrai parce que je veux croire en
l'avenir je veux croire en votre
jeunesse et je veux croire que vous ne
laisserez pas le monde rural loin de de
la modernité et des besoins
contemporains merci Monsieur assouigne
oui c'est un débat qui qui prend son
importance au-delà de ce cré de de du
cœur de de la ruralité parce qu'on
touche à une question démocratique trop
peu souvent discuté dans l'hémicycle
c'est-à-dire toutes les conséquences
qu'implique la révolution numérique y
compris pour l'exercice simple de la
citoyenneté et de la
responsabilité monsieur retaillot a
essayé de dater il a dit que les
engagements ont été pris par un premier
plan un premier plan d'engagement en
ensuite en 2010 et nous sommes obligés
d'y revenir maintenant avec
l'expérience de ce qui tout ce qui n'a
pas été fait de 2003 à à 2012 et on peut
chacun porter une
responsabilité il y avait une
responsabilité mais elle est partagée je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que ce
n'est pas vrai que cette révolution a
été été
appréhendable par l'ensemble des
décideurs y compris des citoyens et des
scientifiques dans toutes ces
conséquences dès
2002 il y a cette contradiction et c'est
bien ici une indication est donnée pour
la
tranchée il y avait des progrès pour
être ne sera que dans la compétition
internationale il fallait les
accompagner et à chaque fois que la
technique permettait d'aller plus loin
et bien mettre le paquet pour aller plus
loin le câble la fibre et cetera et en
même temps on navait pas les moyens de
le faire en même temps et sur l'ensemble
du territoire et pourtant l'exigence
démocratique le démontrer on se disait
c'est pas grave parce que à ce moment-là
tout ne dépendait pas du numérique
aujourd'hui un citoyen qui n'a pas accès
au débit est en situation de très
grandes difficulté y compris pour des
papiers administratifs de base ce
n'était pas le cas il y a 10 ans
aujourd'hui c'est clair et c'est net et
donc y compris au moment où nous allons
passer à la question de la discussion
sur la bande 700 où on va se jeter pour
faire du 4G partout
on ne pourra pas le mettre en
contradiction dans les investissements
avec le fait que partout on est la 3G et
on a accès au débit il faudra pas dire
pour avancer on ne peut pas euh investir
pour au moins monter le palier de ceux
qui n'ont rien aujourd'hui il faudra
faire les deux en même temps ou sinon on
continuera à creuser cette inégalité
territoriale mais surtout civique et je
veux dire que au moment où monsieur
rotaillot l'a dit nettement en faisant
les bilans 2003 2010 que nous a proposé
un pas de plus prenons ce pas parce que
la dynamique est enclenchée et le signe
et l'engagement du gouvernement y
compris quand monsieur le ministre dit
qu'il vient tous les 3 mois ici est un
est quelque chose sur lequel nous
pouvons nous appuyer pour engranger
aller plus loin mais dire que parce
qu'on veut tout le le le premier pas on
le fait pas ce n'est pas la tradition du
Sénat ni de la ruralité qui est plutôt
pragmatique
voilà merci Monsieur beet
oui débat effectivement important
intéressant central pour l'ensemble du
territoire et des populations que nous
représentons mais je crois qu' une
première leçon qu'on peut retirer sans
m'y apesantir c'est qu'à l'évidence la
mise en concurrence dans le secteur de
la téléphonie n'a pas réglé les
problèmes et amène la situation à
laquelle on est confronté aujourd'hui la
France a su s équipé du réseau de
distribution d'électricité il y a
quelques décennies puis de la téléphonie
ça a été rappelé aujourd'hui l'enjeu
c'est effectivement la 4G et la 3G dans
tous les territoires de notre République
et je voudrais évoquer ici une
expérience qui montre bien que l'appel
aux opérateurs privés ne règle pas
systématiquement les situations dans la
métropoes lilloises la métropole
européenne de Lille s'est emparé du
sujet parce qu'il devient central
partout y compris dans une grande
métropole comme celle-là qui comporte
aussi des secteurs ruraux les deux
opérateurs l'opérateur historique
s'occupe des secteurs dans urbains cœur
de métropole où là les travaux
s'engagent un autre opérateur privé est
censé se charger par convention des
secteurs ruraux les travaux n'ont pas
commencé côté autres opérateurs privés
et donc il y a une disparité inquiétante
gênante et qui commence à susciter
beaucoup d'émois et d'inquiétudes chez
les élus par conséquent on prend acte de
cette de cet amendement du gouvernement
mais des intentions sont affichées et
quand monsieur ministre vous dites que
vous vous donnerez les moyens de faire
en sorte que les opérateurs quels qu'ils
soient agissent investissent et règlent
le problème vous me permettrez d'en
douter un peu on s'est malheureusement
privé des outils l'outil existait il y a
quelques années on va pas refaire
l'histoire mais céit un fait et
aujourd'hui on est en difficulté pour
assurer l'égalité d'accès à cette
nouvelle nouveau mode de communication
donc l'amendement de Monsieur retaillot
répondait un peu plus à nos yeux à cette
problématique don voilà la situation
dans laquelle nous trouvons merci
monsieur bquet je n'ai plus de demande
d'explication de vote je passe donc la
parole à Monsieur le Ministre monsieur
fou monsieurou non monsieur fouco vous
avez déjà fait une explication de vote
je ne peux pas vous redonner la
parole oui
oui monsieur le Président je voulais
apporter quelques précisions suite aux
questions qui ont été soulevées par par
plusieurs d'entre vous essayer de dire
pour des raisons rédactionnelles je ne
peux pas accéder à votre à votre demande
parce que euh comme vous le voyez je
vais essayer de de le dérouler avec vous
l'amendement du Gouvernement est est
articulé de telle façon qu'on ne peut
pas écraser tous les délais toutes les
zones dans la Linéa que vous proposez de
remplacer mais je vais essayer de vous
expliquer en quoi on arrive au même
résultat
alors la situation que nous voulons
aborder c'est pour ça que je voulais
répondre en particulier monsieur le
sénateur ce que vous avez dit c'est de
traiter et les centrebourgs et le reste
et donc si vous prenez l'amendement du
Gouvernement et je en faire une lecture
un peu pédestre parce que c'est que
comme ça qu'on rentrera dans
le dans le cheminement du raisonnement
c'est que en effet on commence par les
centrebourgs et on se dit on a un double
objectif le 2G 3G 31 décembre 2016 pour
la 2G premier fin du premier semestre
2017 pour la 3G on a 170 entrebour qui
sont pas couverts en 2G 3000 he en 3G ça
c'est le premier objectif et là c'est ce
qu'on a donc donc dans cet amendement
qui définit le fait qu'on a des projets
de convention qui seront finalisés dans
les 2 mois et le mécanisme que j'évoqué
c'est-à-dire que si les si les
opérateurs n'accèent pas donc aux
engagements pris l'ARCEP sanctionne moi
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
l'arcepp ne va pas jusqu'à sanctionner
parce que lorsqu'elle met en demeure ou
lorsqu'elle notifie généralement les
opérateurs se rangent donc et vous
verrez que c'est comme ça que cela se
passera alors ça c'est le premier bloc
qui couvre les centesbours
sur le sujet des projets de convention
vous l'avez cité très justement monsieur
le sénateur pourquoi c'est rédigé de
cette manière que moi aussi je trouve
très alambiqué parce qu'on a déjà mis un
coup d'accélérateur pour en arriver là
sinon on dormirait encore et dans 6 mois
on pourrait avoir la même discussion par
qu'on disait on négocie on négocie donc
moi on m'a dit on négocie avec les
opérateurs je sais pas depuis combien de
temps ça durait moi je sais que je suis
là depuis 6 mois ça fait manifestement 6
mois que ça dure donc on va finir la
négociation avec les opérateurs d'ici la
fin du mois je les vois avant la fin du
mois tous soit on a des conventions qui
sont conclues avant la nouvelle lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale et on garde
cette rédaction parce que je pourrais
produire les conventions soit les
conventions continuent à patoger et dans
ces cas-là moi je m'engage à modifier
cette rédaction pour que so ce soit plus
des projets de convention mais des
obligations endure dans la loi ure parce
que c'est le seul moyen
d'avancer donc comme ça les sont au
courant les opérateurs sont au courant
si si ils veulent vraiment négocier de
bonne foi ça fait quand même longtemps
ça fait longtemps que c'est évoqué si
les opérateurs veulent négocier de bonne
foi on finira s'ils ne veulent pas
négocier de bonne foi on le mettra en
dur dans la loi ça c'est pour les
centrebourg mais ensuite monsieur le
sénateur on arrive au reste des zones et
pardon si j'étais tout à l'heure trop
allusif mais c'est ça qu'on appelle les
guichets c'est de dire et donc c'est ce
que vous avez dans la modification du
l34-8-5 au début de la page 3 pour moi
de cet de cet amendement on est dans la
même logique les conventions
donc même règle c'est-à-dire que soit on
arrive à se mettre d'accord sur ces
conventions soit on le mettra là aussi
en dur mais c'est de dire on constate
qu'il y a des zones qui ne sont pas
couvertes indépendamment des centrebourg
on n plus dans la logique des
centrebourg et là on dit les
collectivités viennent au guichet unique
et c'est là qu'on prévoit un
cofinancement de l'État on a une poche
de 20 millions d'euros qui permet de
cofinancer pourquoi ça coûte pas un
argent fou hein de déétendre quand on a
le centrebourg qui est couvert aux
alentours moi ce qu'on me dit c'est
environ 100000 € par par zone pour
réussir à aller au-delà de du
centrebourg donc on voit bien qu'avec
les 20 millions déjà mobilisés on peut
en faire pas mal et donc ce qui est
prévu ici c'est de dire toutes les
collectivités qui ne sont pas couvertes
qui ne sont couvertes qu'au niveau du
centrebourg bah viennent à se guicher on
définit les modalités de réponse et de
financement et on les tend et les
opérateurs sont obligés de venir une
fois cet investissement fait parce que
la répartition se fait comment dans les
centrebourgs on le sait c'est les
opérateurs qui viennent qui font
l'antenne et ensuite le financement
courant c'est les opérateurs qui
prennent à charge ici on aura un
investissement public où l'État prendra
une part substantielle qui viendra
étendre la couverture quand elle n'est
limitée qu'au centrebourg mais ensuite
on fait venir les opérateurs pour qu'il
fassent les financement courants c'est
ça la logique mais donc il ces
territoires ne sont pas abandonnés
simplement ils relèvent d'un autre
mécanisme qui est plus complexe puisque
ça suppose d'avoir d'autres antennes
relé quand seul le centrebour est
couvert mais c'est ce qui est vraiment
ici écrit avec la même logique on reste
dans la dans dans l'approche par
convention parce que c'est celle dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui avec
les opérateurs si ces conventions moi je
n'ai pas les garanties d'ici la fin du
mois et qu'elles ne sont pas finalisées
ce sera mis là aussi
endure dans la loi avec un objectif de
temps et de moyens la même chose donc
là-dessus moi je tiens à ce que la
discussion d'aujourd'hui soit pas juste
perçu comme un premier pas ça à mes yeux
ça doit être un dispositif péren ça a
été vous avez largement débattu vous
avez raison il y a eu des initiatives
parlementaires qui ont été prises vous
l'avez porté dans la loi nôre monsieur
le Président je veux dire on a on se
ridiculise sinon collectivement le
Premier ministre au mois de mars a pris
un engagement la parole publique a été
donnée si je vous dis juste on fait un
premier pas là honnête et que dans 6
mois on fait le même constat et ce que
vous dites et qu'on qu'on va voir nos
concitoyens en disant bah oui mais vous
vous êtes pas dans le centrebourg la
belle affaire bon donc c'est une
question de crédibilité collective et je
pense donc qu'il faut en passer par là
donc voilà en tout cas les
clarifications que je voulais apporter
et les engagements que je voulais
prendre maintenant aller créer un fond
de de de péréquation je n'y crois pas
pour ma part je n'y crois pas parce que
pour le coup on parle d'opérateur privés
qui gèent des des fréquences ils ont
donc des obligations on est légitime à
leur donner par la loi si on commence à
créer un fond de préréquation ça veut
dire que on fait des sociétés d'économie
mixte en quelque sorte de la téléphonie
fixe et mobile moi je pense que chacun
doit être à sa place mais il faut
occuper toute sa place et donc il s'agit
pas que l'État redevienne un opérateur
de téléphonie de manière directe ou
indirecte mais il faut que l'État prenne
toute sa place ça veut dire par la loi
mettre les règles que vous souhaitez
dans lesquels on s'engage qui sont
l'égalité d'accès de tous les
territoires à ces services on a pas
besoin d'être un opérateur pour ça on a
simplement besoin de prendre toutes ces
responsabilités quand on est la
puissance publique c'est ce que je vous
propose de faire à travers cette
amendement merci monsieur le ministre je
vais donc mettre au voix l'amendement
1761 rectifié qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté l'article 33 sesd est donc
ainsi rédigé et l'amendement 1400
tombe nous passons à des articles
additionnels après l'article 33 cpè D
avec l'amendement 130 rectifier bis qui
le présente allez-y mon chers
collègue oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc nous proposons par cet amendement
d'insérer un article additionnel qui
serait ainsi rédigé le 4 de l'article
l14 1251 du code général des
collectivités territoriales est complété
par un alinéa ainsi rédigé lorsque ces
mêmes conditions sont réunies les
collectivités peuvent subventionner
l'équipement des logements et locaux à
usage professionnel en vue de leur
connexion au réseau de communications
électroniques ouvert au public l'objet
de cet article c'est que le raccordement
final des particuliers et des
entreprises au réseau de communication
électronique à comme à très haut débit
peut avoir un coût élevé dans les zones
rurales ou difficiles d'accès je ne
développerai pas je crois que le débat
que nous venons d'avoir était
parfaitement clair sur ce sujet c'est
notamment le cas pour ce qui est du
raccordement à la boucle locale à très
haut débit en fibre optiquees les
collectivités territoriales sont dès
lors justifiés à intervenir afin de
soutenir l'effort financier de ces
particuliers entreprises aussi
convient-il de sécuriser le cadre de
cette intervention en l'autorisant
expressément dans le cadre de l'article
l14251 du code général des collectivités
territoriales qui fonde l'action des
collectivités en matière de réseau à
haut et très haut débit effectivement il
y a aussi des problèmes de de réseau et
d'infrastructure mais il y a des
problèmes de raccordement final et
ensuite des problèmes de
tarification je vous remercie merci quel
est l'avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur cet amendement nous semble
sécurisé juridique une pratique qui est
déjà le fait de nombreuses collectivités
tout en respectant le principe de
neutralité technologique prévu par le
droit européen et c'est un avis
favorable monsieur le ministre oui c'est
ce que vient de dire Madame la
rapporteur est tout à fait juste on le
constate déjà dans les projets qui sont
soumis à la mission très haut débit donc
moi j'avais envie de vous dire que votre
amendement est satisfait parce que c'est
déjà la pratique il vient en effet la
sécuriser donc j'auris un avis de soit
un retrait parce qu'il est satisfait
sinon un avis de sagesse monsieur vous
m' demand la parole pour explication de
vote oui monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la rapporteur euh je
voulais proposer euh à mon sens une un
sous-amendement ou une précision à cet
amendement car je crains que cet
amendement ouvre la porte d'un
financement par les collectivités dans
les zones conventionnées il me
semblerait utile et nécessaire que l'on
précise que cette cette pratique se
réalise hors zone
conventionnée
il n'y a de si vous n'avez pas une
proposition écrite monsieur Chel je ne
peux pas donner suite à votre il suffit
de rajouter hors zone conventionné mais
où alors sur
le sur le le texte qui qui dit lorsque
c'est mêmes conditions sont réunies les
collectivités peuvent subventionner
l'équipement et cetera et cetera hors
zone
conventionné et cetera et cetera à quel
endroit précis aès ouvert au public à la
fin de la phrase à la fin de la phrase
non conventionné c'est ça hors zone
conventionné alors quel est l'avis de la
commission sur ces
amendements avis de sagesse sur ce
sous-amendement je sais pas il faut voir
les auteurs de l'amendement mais
monsieur
Alizard monsieur Alizard
oui monsieur le Président effectivement
c'est une précision qui ne figure pas
dans l'amendement qui peut sembler sage
puisque en fait la crainte je crois de
mon collègue c'est que soit certaines
entreprises mais aussi certains
opérateurs puissent profiterune certaine
ouverture liée à cette amendement pour
chercher à bénéficier d'aide sur des
secteurs déjà conventionnés et qui est
rentable donc on peut craindre
qu'effectivement ces exceptions aillent
à l'encontre un petit peu du débat que
nous avons eu précédemment donc si du
point de vue de la procédure on peut
rajouter ces trois mots à l'amendement
je serais personnellement favorable à ce
sous-amendement si c'est possible
monsieur le Président donc vous le
rectifiez oui absolument monsieur
Guillaume monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
min mes chers collègues je v simplement
dire que le rapporteur vient de dire que
la Commission avait un avis de sagesse
sur le sousamendement j'ai envie de dire
ça geste quand même assez négatif parce
que les auteurs monsieur delège et
monsieur rotaillot avait signalé combien
il tenait à l'intégrité de l'amendement
et la commission euh ne peut que
rappeler ce point-là et il nous semble
difficile en l'absence des auteurs euh
de changer quand même un peu
substantiellement le sens de
l'amendement voilà c'est juste un
problème de méthode hein monsieur
Alizard il vous a proposé en fait de
renoncer à ce t d'amendement bien
écoutez moi je suis cosignataire de
l'amendement tel qu'il a été rédigé à
l'origine donc j'y suis forcément
favorable maintenant il me semblait que
la remarque de mon collègue était pas
dénué de bon sens
monsieur non si du point de vue
procédure c'est pas possible je
maintiens l'amendement tel qu'il est
qu'il est rédigé l'amendement initial
absol parfait alors madame Gatel pour
explication de vote sur l'amendement
initial puis monsieur Guillaume merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je suis aussi coignataire de
cette amendement qui émane du
département d'î et vilaines et qui ne
remet nullement en cause tout ce qui a
été dit par nos collègues sur l'enjeu
national de l'équilibre territorial sur
le déploiement du haut débit et on l'a
dit de manière collective et sans
polémique de la responsabilité de l'État
mais je crois qu'il y a dans ce
territoire comme dans d'autres une
volonté des communes ou des communautés
de se prendre en charge selon le
principe du êre toi et le ciel tédin et
que pour garder aussi du développement
économique nous sommes amenés à demander
à ce qu'une commune une communauté
puisse avoir une contribution financière
faute de quoi la ruralité continuera à
devenir hyper ruralité et que je
rappelle pour en avoir discuté encore
hier soir avec Monsieur delè et Monsieur
retaillot il me semble préférrable pour
sécuriser la situation que l'amendement
reste en l'état car aujourd'hui quand
une collectivité veut intervenir on lui
oppose une jurisprudence du Conseil
d'État dite arrêt choria de
1993 qui interdit à toute collectivité
d'intervenir financièrement s'il n'y a
pas de disposition législative précise
donc moi je souhaite que l'on puisse
suivre l'avis du rapporteur et qu'on se
maintienne dans cet amendement en l'état
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur Guillaume monsieur le Président
Monsieur le le ministre moi cet
amendement me gêne il me gêne parce que
pendant
2h nous avons évoqué que les
collectivités locales mettaient trop
d'argent et l'État pas assez et qu'il
fallait que l'État arrose partout en
ville comme en zone rurale et là cet
amendement
veut soi-disant sécuriser un fait de
dire très clairement les collectivités
locales peuvent finan financer les les
locaux alors moi à titre personnel et
très tranquillement sans aucune moi j'y
suis très opposé je pense que le rôle
des collectivités locales devrait être
d'amener les tuyaux de faire en sorte
qu'il a des usages de faire la
couverture numérique comme dans la loi
aujourd'hui cette possibilité existe
déjà je j'aurais tendance à dire ne
l'écrivons pas parce que si nous
écrivons connaissant bien les arcanes de
l'État je parle pas des gouvernements de
droite ou de gauche des arcanes de
l'État si nous écrivons dans la loi
que les collectivités locales peuvent
subventionner l'équipement des logements
et locau usage professionnel alors
racontez-vous pas d'histoire he ou il y
aura plus que les collectivités locales
qui seront là pour les financer et
l'État s'échappera donc moi j'aurais
tendance à dire je comprends là on
travaille tous dans la même direction
pour faire la couverture la meilleure
pour aider les locaux commerciaux et
cetera moi j'ai quand même un petit
doute parce que le revers de la médaille
le boomerang lorsquil va revenir l'État
va nous dire bah vous l'avez voté donc
nous maintenant on ne bouge plus à vous
de le faire faut vraiment regarder ça de
près monsieur Guillaume bien il n'y a
plus d'explication de
vote monsieur Alizard l'aur de
l'amendement enfin l'un des auteurs
oui simplement une petite précision
monsieur le président rappelez quand
même que derrière cet amendement il y a
la problématique des coûts et des coûts
d'abonnement et des coûts de
raccordement pour les entreprises ça a
été abordé par ma collègue il y a
quelques instants et les opérateurs sur
ces sujets-là et notamment sur les zones
non conventionnées proposeent des tarifs
qui sont généralement exorbitants donc
l'objectif de l'amendement c'est aussi
de créer un appel par rapport à ce
problème c'est pour ça que je maintiens
l'amendement et que je souhaiterais
qu'il soit adopté
l'amendement est maintenu et je le mets
au voix avec un avis favorable de la
commission et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est
pour
alors 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 24 25 qui est
contre 25 bon il est adopté attends 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 21 22 23 24 25 non il y a doute il
y a il y a doute alors que ceux qui sont
pour veuillent bien se
lever je veux égalité moi ouais 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 22 23 24 25 26 que ceux qui
seulent contre qui sont contre veuillent
bien se lever 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25
26 27 il n'est pas adopté il n'est pas
adopté nous passons au 573 rectifié qui
le
présente le
573 estil
défendu madame Borin de sa monsieur
Maé monsieur le Président cet amendement
vise à améliorer la cohérence du
dispositif prévu pour les projets
d'installation radioélectrique par la
loi du 9 février 2015 relative à la
sobriété à la transparence à
l'information à la concertation en
matière d'exposition aux ondes
électromagnétiques dite PPL abeille
cette proposition de loi visait
notamment à renforcer l'information des
maires et des présidents
d'intercommunalité en cas d'installation
d'antenne ou de modification
substantielle de leurs conditions
d'utilisation l'article L
34-9-1 du code des postes et des et des
communications électroniques modifié par
cette loi prévoit un délai de 2 mois
entre le dépôt du dossier d'information
et la demande d'autorisation d'urbanisme
pour un projet portant sur une nouvelle
installation radioélectrique le même
article prévoit un délai d'au moins de
mois entre le dépôt du dossier
d'information et le début des travaux
pour un projet de modification
substantielle d'une installation
existance or ces projets de modification
vous en conviendraz présentent des
enjeux de même importance sinon moindre
que les projets de nouvelles
installations les délais imposés
manquent donc de cohérence donc le
présent amendement propose ainsi de
fixer précisément à 2 mois le dél exig
pour un projet de modification
substantielle d'une installation
existence question de bon sens merci
quel est l'avis de la commission madame
la
rapporteur cet amendement nous paraît
bon sens ce délai ne peut être plus long
que celui séparant le dépôt du dossier
avec l'implantation d'e nouvelle
installation radioélectrique puisque
l'enjeu de cette dernière est plus
important aligner ces deux délà de moin
nous semble donc cohérent et c'est un
avis favorable avis du gouvernement
sagesse bien je le mets au voix avec un
avis favorable de la commission des
sagesse du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté nous passons à l'article 33
ctiè avec un amendement de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur oui c'est un
amendement de précision rédactionnelle
merci Monsieur le
Ministre votre
avis le 1699
rédactionnel favorable très bien je le
mets au voix avec deux avis favorable
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je mets au voix
l'article 33 seè même vote même vote
l'article 33 cè est adopté nous passons
à deux articles additionnels après
l'article 33
ctièce pardon un amendement 969 rectifié
terre monsieur le leu merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur monieur le ministre
madame le rapporteur c'est un amendement
d'équilibre et de compromis que je vous
propose afin d'apaiser un débat qui
s'est installé depuis près de 10 ans et
qui oppose un certain nombre d'acteurs
de l'audiovisuel je rappelle que le
Conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel a la
charge et la mission de par la loi de
fixer les règles de la numérotation des
chaînes et que la loi précise que si les
distributeurs de service de
l'offre de programme comprend les
services nationaux de télévision en
diffusion atienne en mode numérique ils
doivent
impérativement le mettre dans début de
numérotation mais s'ils ne le respectent
pas ils peuvent ils doivent le différer
dans des numérotations au-delà de la
première unité d'une centaine et c'est
ainsi que euh un certain nombre
d'opérateurs euh respectent la
numérotation telle que l'a préconisé le
CSA mais qu'un certain nombre d'autres
euh font leur numérotation thématique et
diffèrent au-delà de la numérotation en
général 300 le bloc TNT ce qu'on appelle
le bloc TNP TNT ce sujet divise les
acteurs et ces règles de numérotation
sont sont critiquées par certains
acteurs de la TNT qui souhaitent que
l'ensemble des distributeurs respectent
la numérotation que l'on qualifie de
logique mais dont on verra qu'elle n'est
pas si logique que ça elle respecte la
numérotation prévue par le
CSA le Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel a souvent rappelé cette
doctrine en disant que l'ensemble des
distributeurs quel que soit leur mode de
diffusion respecte la numérotation dite
logique mais les opposants à cette
mesure font valoir que la numérotation
par thématique par thématique
différentes dans la numérotation qui
figurent dans leur plan de service
assure une cohérence éditoriale entre
les chaînes qui relèvent du même univers
et répond à une attente des abonnés ce
qui est également cohérent et
compréhensible et beaucoup d'abonnés au
fond s'abonnent et prennent un
abonnement dans le le réseau payant pour
justement être servi d'une cohérence
dans les lignes éditorial lié aux
thématiques
exprimées de plus euh les tenant de de
de de de du secteur disons payant euh
évoque l'aspect économique et ce qui
justifie notre intervention dans le
cadre de cette de cette loi c'est que la
contribution à la production est quand
même beaucoup plus importante par le
secteur de distribution payant que par
les chaînes de la Tet notamment les
nouvelles alors madame la présidente de
la commission de la culture Madame
Catherine marin de sali consciente qu'il
y avait
là une difficulté d'application
juridique à questionné le CSA pour avoir
un peu l'actualisation de sa position
sur ce sujet et nous avons donc eu par
l'intermédiaire de la présidente une
réponse le 1er avril dans laquelle le
CSA bah confirme sa doctrine historique
mais ouvre une porte
extrêmement utile pardon oui et en en en
demandant à ce que soit reconnu
également les intérêts économiques des
euh des des des distributeurs alors
l'amendement il est simple il impose la
numérotation logique mais il permet aux
opérateurs distributeurs de proposer aux
téléspectateurs une autre numéro
votation transparente et sous la
surveillance du CSA on rend la main au
téléspectateur ce qui nous paraît
être un progrès cet amendement satisfait
un grande partie des acteurs et je vous
demande de bien vouloir l'adopter le
1791 monsieur
Assouline sous amende l'amendement oui
les chaînne de la TNT donc lancée en
2005 représente une offre gratuite et
diverse mais elle ne constitue cependant
qu'une partie du paysage audiovisuel
français sont très largement exposés par
le biais de ce mode de diffusion et
accessible au 27,2 millions de foyers
équipés d'un récepteur de télévision sur
ces 27 millions seul 30 % soit 3,7 %
millions de foyers seulement d'entre eux
ne reçoivent que la TNT donc ça a été
expliqué par mon collègue lu il faut
répondre àx téléspectateurs qui sont sur
un mode sur l'autre ou sur les deux et
que surtout il puissent s'y reconnaître
mais aussi que les acteurs soient
suffisamment exposés pour pouvoir ne pas
subir l'avantage d'une exposition à l'un
ou l'autre mode donc trouver l'équilibre
et à la suite de l'amendement qu'a
déposé notre collègue d'aliier qui en
commission spéciale qui déséquilibrait
un peu notre président de la commission
Culture a de demander au CSA euh de se
prononcer sur sa vision des choses
euh il s'est clairement prononcé en
faveur d'une solution préservant à la
fois les intérêts des téléspectateurs
qui apprécient la numérotation
thématique mise en place par les
distributeurs et ceux qui recherch r une
numérotation uniforme sur l'ensemble des
plateformes hertienne ou autres réseau
l'Autorité de régulation a estimé qu'une
solution euh pouvait exister à la fois
de présenter la numérotation logique sur
toutes les offres des distributeurs mais
aussi d'avoir accès à une numérotation
thématique qui satisfaaiit les
téléspectateurs mais préserverit en
outre les intérêts économiques tant des
chaînes de la TNT que des groupes des
chaînes payantes à partir de là
l'amendement que a proposé monsieur
Leleu cherche à trouver cette ligne
médiane je veux rappeler
que il faut trouver cet équilibre et
dans cet équilibre il faut peut-être
préciser et c'est l'objet de mon
sous-amendement la précision qui vient
renforcer ce que propose monsieur lu
dans cet équilibre c'est que une fois
qu'on renvoie au CSA le soin
de présenter les choses il faut que la
mise en œuvre soit précisée pour que il
n'y ait
pas euh euh une présentation du double
système de numérotation qui euh qui soit
euh euh disons euh euh qui privilégie un
mode ou un autre bien donc quand
monsieur Leleu
dit nous souhaitons donc préciser que
les distributeurs euh euh qui
proposeront dans leur offre à la fois
une reprise des chaînes TNT et d'autres
services payants il dit peuvent moi je
dis sont tenus d'accompagner ses offres
du double système de numérotation le
téléspectateur consommateur restant ce
que je précise toujours libre de choisir
l'un ou l'autre donc
un j'insiste dans ma précision sur le
fait que le téléspectateur doit toujours
avoir le moyen de choisir la
numérotation mais aussi que on soit tenu
de lui offrir les deux et non pas l'une
de préférence encore moins en occultant
une autre donc au lieu de peuv qui est
le terme de Monsieur L leu je dis doiv
et je précise qu'en dernier le le
téléspectateur doit avoir la liberté je
pense que ça va ça va ensemble très bien
alors le 1452 rectifié est présenté par
qui Monsieur
B ben non va
je crois que oui voilà nous allons à peu
près tous dans le même sens monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues les chaînes gratuites on ont
vocation à être accessi par l'ensemble
de la population quel que soit le mode
de réception de la télévision qu'ils
choisissent or même si les chaînes de la
TNT sont bien présentes dans les plans
de service des différents distributeurs
de services le téléspectateur abonné
n'est pas en mesure de les retrouver
selon leur numérotation logique
contrairement au téléspectateur qui
reçoit gratuitement la TNT sur son
téléviseur ainsi le téléspectateur
abonné est littéralement perdu ce qui
préjudicie fortement à l'intérêt général
des téléspectateurs et donc des foyers
français dont l'engouement pour la TNT
n'est plus à démontrer à titre d'exemple
non limitatif BFM TV dont la
numérotation analogique attribuée par le
CSA et le 15 se trouve relégué au numéro
103 sur Canal Satellite et au numéro 43
sur numérique câble il en est de même
avec Cherry 25 et gully il existe par
conséquent une inégalité d'accès aux
chaînes gratuit de la TNT par les
téléspectateurs qui méconnaît
manifestement les les exigences
d'intérêt général liées aux attentes
légitimes des téléspectateurs vis-à-vis
des chaînes autorisées par l'autorité
sectorielle à occuper le domaine public
une modification législative imposant en
toute circonstance au distributeurs de
service de respecter la numérotation
logique définie par le CSA devrait
s'imposer tant il est manifeste que
l'objectif d'intérêt général poursuivi
n'est pas
atteint merci alors avis de la
commission
sur l'amendement le sous-amendement et
le 1452 r alors sur le sous-amendement
il a été déposé tardivement donc la
Commission n'a pas pu donner son avis
puisqu'il est arrivé après que nous nous
soyons réunis je vous fais donc part de
l'avis de Madame la rapporteur Dominique
estrzi qui qui trouve que le sousam
amendement complique plutôt la rédaction
de l'article 969 et modifie l'équilibre
de l'amendement euh 569 qui comme ça a
été dit par notre collègue Leleu a fait
l'objet de longue et délicate
négociation entre les différents acteurs
concernés donc c'est une demande de
retrait euh sur le sur les deux autres
amendements donc je vais rappeler un peu
le le contexte nous abordons le délicat
et ça a été dit ancien problème de la
numérotation des chaînes de télévision
de la TNT le débat sur la numérotation
des chaînes oppose deux catégories de
distributeurs cela a été dit les
distributeurs de la TNT gratuite 25
chaînes aujourd'hui qui souhaite que
soit souhait que soit imposé à
l'ensemble des distributeurs
l'obligation de proposer ce qu'on
appelle la numérotation logique des
chaînes qui s'appuie sur leur numéro
logique attribué par le CSA je vais
tirer mon pas et les distributeurs de la
TNT payante demande au contraire à ne
pouvoir proposer qu'une numérotation
dite thématique de l'ensemble des
chaînes c'est-à-dire une une
numérotation regroupant et organisant
les chaînes par thème la loi sur
l'audiovisuel du 30 septembre 1986 en
l'état prévoit un système hybride qui il
est vrai ne satisfait réellement
personne donc face au demandes
d'évolution deux solutions sont
envisageables celle qui est proposée par
l'amendement de notre collègue l le qui
consiste en un compromis on l'a dit qui
laisse les distributeurs libres de
proposer les deux types de numérotation
et à tout le moins la numérotation
logique c'est à l'usager qu'il
reviendrait dans ce cas de choisir le
type de numérotation qui lui convient le
mieux alors l'autre solution plus
radicale proposée par l'amendement 1452
de notre collègue d'allier qui a défendu
madame de roménie elle impose le respect
de la numérotation logique à tous les
distributeurs nous préférons le premier
amendement donc celui que qu'a exprimé
monsieur lolu parce que il s'agit en
effet de cette rédaction de compromis
qui satisfait tous les acteurs y compris
le CSA qui avait été saisi par notre
collègue madame main de sali l'autre à
l'opposé l'autre amendement retient une
solution un peu trop radical peu raliste
dans sa mise en œuvre et au coût très
élevé pour les chaînes concernées donc
c'est un vote donc favorable pour
l'amendement
969 et une demande de retrait pour
l'amendement présenté par Madame de
romedi merci Monsieur le Ministre quel
est l'avis du Gouvernement oui sur sur
l'amendement 96 969 rectifié terre
présenté par Monsieur L leu j'aurais un
avis de sagesse pour les les raisons
évoquées par Madame la rapporteur
j'aurai le même avis de sagesse pour le
le sous-amendement parce que je pense en
effet qu'il vient préciser euh utilement
la la la rédaction euh du euh ce compte
alinéa euh en en clarifiant en
particulier
euh l'articulation entre la première et
la deuxème phrase donc euh pour ma part
il me semble qu'il vient en effet qui
renforce la logique qui a été présentée
par euh euh Monsieur L leu donc j'aurais
également un avis de sagesse et j'aurais
plutôt une invitation au retrait sur le
1405 52 qui qui poursuit le même
objectif mais dont la rédaction semble
moins finalisée que celle du 969
rectifiire Monsieur assouine Votre
sousamendement pardon est maintenu il
est maintenu très bien donc je le mets
au voix ah Monsieur L pardon
excusez-moi madame de oui merci monsieur
le Président je voudrais effectivement
faire quelques commentaires sur le débat
qui vient de s'instaurer euh
l'amendement que je vous propose est
l'aboutissement d'un travail de
plusieurs semaines de concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs que ce soit le
CSA l'éonant de la de de la numérotation
logique et les tenant de la numérotation
on va dire thématique et et plus libre à
la disposition du téléspectateur c'est
un travail extrêmement précis où chaque
mot compte il fait aujourd'hui si ce
l'enthousiasme de tout le monde mais
c'est rare dans le compromis il fait au
moins l'acceptation de tout le monde et
moi je souhaite que cet amendement reste
dans la rédaction tel qu'il a été le
résultat de l'ensemble de cette
concertation et tout changement et je
demande à notre collègue assoulinene de
ne pas le maintenir son sous-amendement
parce qu'il il ront l'équilibre qui a
été trouvé et on va relancer dans le
monde de l'audiovisuel une une une
opposition qui qui me paraît pas
souhaitable donc je demande à ce que
l'amendement issu de ce travail
d'équilibre et d'harmonie soit adopté
tel qu'il a été proposé et tel qu'il est
le résultat de cette concertation quant
à l'amendement de notre collègue d'aller
je le comprends mais il cristallise la
position on va dire historique du CSA
mais qui a considérablement évolué dans
le panorama audiovisuel et notamment
pour des raisons économiques parce que
quand même négligeons pas la
contribution que ce soit à la création
ou que ce soit à la production des
opérateurs câblés qui certes sont payant
mais apporent énormément dans le dans
dans dans l'industrie
culturelle madame
deromedi nous soutenons la l'amendement
de Monsieur Leleu donc je je donc le
1452 rectifié est retiré c'est bien ça
d'accord il est retiré madame la
Présidente Maurin de sa
oui je voulais juste apporter une
précision sans doute utile euh monsieur
lu a très bien rappelé l'équilibre
délicat et subtil qui a été atteint
après un travail bien sûr de de
concertation avec les acteurs concernés
au-delà de la décision qui a été rendue
par le le CSA qui d'ailleurs a pris un
certain nombre de de temps pour un
certain temps pardonnez-moi pour
retravailler un sujet qui n'allait pas
de n'allait pas de soi euh je dirais que
les acteurs en présence ne sont pas
particulièrement demandeurs d'une
amélioration de l'amendement en l'état
monsieur Assouline bien entendu tente
lui aussi d'apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice pour en faire quelque chose le
plus partagé le plus clair possible mais
les acteurs ne sont pas du tout
demandeurs quel qu'ils soit vous savez
que c'est deux séries d'acteurs les
acteurs la TNT les acteurs des chaînes
PN aucun n'est demandeur de précision
supplémentaire par rapport à à
l'amendement au contraire je crois que
ça n'inquiéterait plutôt certain que de
toucher à cet équilibre subtilement
atteint donc moi je mets en garde ça été
un travail un petit peu long de notre
commission il porte ses fruits
aujourd'hui il satisfait l'ensemble des
parties prenantes peut-être
restonsonsnous la sagesse de
l'amendement de Monsieur Leleu merci
Monsieur
asouine Je je je veux pas qu'on laisse
entendre dans l'hémicycle qui aurait la
sagesse d'un côté euh d'autant que je
soutiens moi dans cet effort de
consensus dans cet effort de
rassemblement et donc de grande sagesse
je soutiens et je m'inscris dans ce qu'a
proposé monsieur lu ça fait un certain
nombre d'années que je travaille avec
grande précision sur le secteur de
l'audiovisuel au au service du Sénat et
donc les acteurs je les connais et vous
pensez bien que quand je présente cet
amendement je les ai écouté
aussi mais j'ai appris une
chose de tout ce travail sur le secteur
des médias c'est que c'est un secteur où
on se fait appeler par tout le monde
tous les
jours et que bien entendu chacun d'entre
eux défend ses intérêts mais toujours en
disant que c'est l'intérêt général ou
sinon il s'adresseraiit pas à nous et
l'intérêt général devient toujours très
contradictoire on appelle ça la pression
des lobbying et cetera j'ai essayé en
tout temps et vous pouvez le voir y
compris sur la question de la des
revances de fréquence d'écouter tout le
monde mais ensuite de dire ce qui est à
mon avis l'intérêt
général en essayant de faire quel
consensus mais c'est la représentation
qui décide c'est pas je ne sais qui donc
c'est un point de
vue politique équilibré et croyez-en mon
expérience je pense qu'il se
situe exactement dans un domaine où il y
a des bouleversements et où même
l'acceptation de ce que l'on appelle la
numérotation logique est bouleversée par
la révolution numérique c'est quoi la
logique si on avait appris à nos enfants
que la logique c'est 1 2 3 4 5 ça c'est
logique ben il serait pas très bon ni en
math ni en géométrie c'est un peu plus
complexe que ça et donc la logique peut
être quand il y a un tel foisonnement de
des FO
200 de se dire tiens je veux voir de
l'info j'ai un thématique info et là je
vais choisir dans les chaînes d'info il
y a sport il y a culture il y a cinéma
donc ça aussi c'est logique je comprends
que certains disent la seule logique
c'est de 1 à 24 et plus on est loin dans
le numéro plus on sera pe exposé donc il
faut les
préserver mais je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui on est dans sur une loi qui
ne concerne pas l'audiovisuel et donc on
essaie de raccrocher un
truc on aurait dû se pencher sur une loi
audiovisuelle je l'ai dit depuis
longtemps parce qu' il y a 1000
problèmes avec cette révolution
médiatique et on ferait des choses
logiques la numérotation la revente des
fréquences et cetera et tout ça aurait
une logique parce qu'on est en train de
parler avec un une polémique sur la
fréquence qui s'appelle numéro 23
elle s'est appelé numéro 23 c'était son
principal argument c'était son principal
argument elle s'appelait numéro 23 bien
et donc elle était devant la 300 qui
pouvait être une chaîne qui je dis au
hasard qui a beaucoup plus disons
d'impact de de souci de la création de
la diversité et cetera pourquoi elle
serait devant donc mon
sous-amendement va complètement dans
votre sens de l'équilibre on propose les
deux ce que vous appelez la logique 1 2
3 4 5 6 et cetera les
thématique ceux qui ont des intérêts
économiques à la première sont préservés
ceux qui ont des intérêts économiques et
la deuxième ce qui est qui sont des
grands groupes vous les connaissez aussi
sont préservés et ils ont des
obligations culturell et
d'investissement par exemple canal
l'investissement dans le cinéma il est
déjà concurrencé sur le sport comme vous
le savez bon donc les deux et dans votre
rédaction vous dites peuvent donc j'ai
peur moi qu'ensuite celui qui va juger
le
peuve décide une hiérarchie dans les
deux puisque c'est pas obligé moi je
propose qu'on fasse les deux et qu'on
donne le moyen aux
téléspectateurs d'avoir toujours le
choix et de faire son
choix voilà et puis demain on pourra
préciser parce que la révolution va
continuer des chaînes vont disparaître
des fusions de groupes des numéros vont
changer des bouquets vont changer mais
pour l'instant je vous demande cette
précision qui va complètement dans votre
sens qui est sage qui est précise et qui
tient compte non seulement des acteurs
mais de ce que le Parlement peut à un
moment donné dire pour être dépendant de
personne et faire son choix en toute
indépendance et moi quand j'ai proposé
la taxation sur des reventes au moment
de bolorer canal
aujourd'hui je suis à l'aise pour faire
la même chose quand il y a la numéro 23
et certains ont à l'époque choisi non on
a des pressions de tous les côtés on
reste au
milieu bien alors je mets au voix donc
le sous-amendement
1791 avec un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour le
sous-amendement avis défavorable de la
commission vous naviez pas précisé
madame non non vous avez non c'était un
avis de retrait
oui ce qui n'est pas un avis défavorable
alors je remets au voix qui est pour cet
amendement
1791 qui est contre
re
il n'est pas adopté je mets donc au voit
maintenant l'amendement 969 rectifié TER
avec un avis favorable de la commission
il a un avis de sagesse du gouvernement
qui est
pour qui est
contre il est donc adopté et le
1452 avait été retiré nous en arrivons
au 33
è a avec un amendement 1519 du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre oui le le le
33è a et l'objet de cet amendement est
donc de de de supprimer le le dit
article en imposant le carcan d'un
modèle unique de contrat restreint très
fortement la la liberté contractuel des
acteurs économiques et une telle
restruction nous apparaît
disproportionnée et inadaptée pour
régler les difficultés actuelles de
l'hôtellerie française les
professionnels eux-mêmes d'ailleurs le
le reconnaissent et cet amendement ne
fait aujourd'hui pas consensus dans la
profession il y a une partie des hôelers
qui doutent en effet fortement de
l'utilité de cette mesure pour améliorer
leur relations commerciales avec les
sites de réservation en ligne cette
relation commerciale est aujourd'hui
examinée de façon très approfondie par
deux instances l'Autorité de la
concurrence d'une part qui a été saisie
par les syndicats professionnels et plus
récemment par le groupe accord je l'ai
également saisi à titre consultatif sur
le sujet et le tribunal de commerce de
Paris par ailleurs qui doit se prononcer
sur la légalité de certaines clauses des
contrats donc de ces sites de
réservation en ligne à la demande là
aussi de mes services qui ont déposé des
assignations et donc il me paraît plus
sage d'attendre les retours de ces deux
services celle-ci devrait en effet en
faisant juris jurisprudence pour ce qui
est du tribunal de commerce et en
éclairant le débat pour l'Autorité de la
concurrence nous permett d'améliorer le
cadre régulatoire plutôt que de proposer
le carcan du modèle unique de contrat
ici
déposé merci quel est l'avis de la
commission donc c'est cet article 33sa
qui a introduit la commission spéciale à
l'initiative de notre collègue
Jean-Claude Lenoir prévoit l'obligation
de conclure un contrat de mandat dans
les relations commerciales entre
hôteliers et plateforme de réservation
en ligne en V en vue de mieux les
encadrer et ainsi de les
rééquilibrer en l'adoptant nous avons
voulu marquer notre volonté d'avancer
sur ce sujet qui en instance depuis
plusieurs années et qui cause préjudice
à nos hôteliers mais nous avions indiqué
dans le rapport de la mission que notre
opposition pour la séance serait en
grande partie déterminée par les
avancées les plus récentes du dossier or
nous avons sur ce sujet plusieurs
recours et plusieurs consultations en
cours monsieur le ministre vient de les
évoquer dans l'attente de ces évolutions
la commission a donné un vite sagesse à
cet amendement et aux deux suivants qui
sont sur une suppression partielle
sachant qu'il paraît intéressant de
conserver cet article en l'état durant
la navette pour le cas où ces évolutions
ne seraient pas satisfaisantes et
nécessiteraient légiférer nous vous
proposons une sagesse négative voire
très négative à cet amendement de
suppression globale d'article ainsi
qu'au deux amendement de suppression
partielle
suivant bien je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 15A madame de Messine
pardon pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
rapporteur il est très important de
conserver cette article et je voudrais
expliquer pourquoi même si effectivement
il y a un certain nombre de de dossiers
en justice actuellement mais je pense
que l'affaire est grave et ce serait
peut-être bien si Monsieur le Ministre
pouvait
m'écouter mais ça semble difficile voilà
Monsieur le Ministre euh effectivement
euh c'est une affaire très importante
euh c'est vrai que l'émergence ces
agences en ligne correspondent à un
nouveau mode de consommation
incontournable
mais ce nouveau ce nouveau mode de
consommation et ces agences en ligne ont
imposé un modèle économique dangereux et
pas tenable à long terme d'abord bon il
faut savoir qu'il qu'il demande ils
prennent 20 % de commission et proposent
des prix les plus bas en en empêchant la
liberté pour les pour les hôteliers et
tous les opérateurs du tourisme qui
passent par ces agences de faire en les
empêchant de de de pouvoir eux-mêmes
payer à des tarifs normaux de plus euh
autre inconvénient ces agences en ligne
récupèrent à bon compte les fichiers
clients alors monsieur le ministre vous
dites qu'il n'y a pas de consensus
euh effectivement la diversité des
acteurs et ben montre que et je pense
c'est à cause de la diversité des
acteurs et je pense que vous voulez
parler du qu'il y a pas de consensus
entre les gros opérateurs et les petits
opérateurs qui eux sont très nombreux
très nombreux et sont ceux qui aussi
maille le mieux notre
territoire il faut reconnaître qu'on est
dans beaucoup de domaines avec
l'émergence des nouvelles technologies
sous la domination totale d'OP
internationaux qui n'ont que faire de
notre intérêt
général
donc vous le savez monsieur le ministre
notre économie touristique est très
importante dans notre pays elle est très
importante pour l'emploi elle est très
importante aussi pour l'aménagement du
territoire c'est pas une petite affaire
et je pense qu'il y a une impérieuse
nécessité de procéder à la mise en place
de règles qui
permettent à la à la biodiversité de
notre tourisme d'exister car c'est ce
qui fait qui en fait sa force et aussi
le fait qu'on est la première
destination touristique au
monde merci pas d'autre explication de
vote donc je mets au voix l'amendement
1519 du gouvernement avec un avis de
sagesse négative à monsieur le Président
pardon oui monsieur Président mes chers
collègues je voulais juste dire au
niveau procédural il me semble utile que
on maintienne cet article dans dans la
navette et je veux rappeler que le
rapporteur a émis un avis de sagesse
très négative et que je pense que le
reste la suite du processus pourra
éventuellement permettre en dialogue
avec le gouvernement et l'Assemblée
peut-être de peaufiner l'article mais
qu'il est utile que ce sujet reste dans
le dans le texte comme Madame debessine
vient de le dire tout à fait
utilement donc c'est plutôt un avis
défavorable très négatif très négatif
très né alors je mets au voix
l'amendement 1519 avec un avis de
sagesse très négative de la commission
qui est
pour qui est pour cet
amendement bon qui est contre alors bon
donc cet amendement n'est pas adopté l'
l'article n'est pas supprimé et nous en
arrivons à deux amendements sur cet
article en discussion commune et
identique le 184 rectifier desquèes
monsieur
comen monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame rapporteur mes chers
collègues François Hollande a décrété
lors de la clôture des Assises du
tourisme en l'été 2013 une mobilisation
générale pour redynamiser le tourisme
français l'ériigant même en cause
national l'ambition du président de la
République est d'accueillir 100 millions
de touristes étrangers d'ici à 2030 dans
un marché mondial qui devrait atteindre
les 2 milliards pour réussir ce Paris la
France s'est dotée d'une agence de
développement touristique à tout France
pour promouvoir le tourisme dans son
ensemble et favoriser le développement
du secteur surtout cet organisme unique
en son genre doit permettre d'éclairer
sur les difficultés du secteur et le
rapport parlementaire afférant àoiné
plusieurs transformations qui affectent
le secteur touristique le premier
d'entre eux et la des interter médiation
numérique c'est-à-dire l'utilisation des
outils numériques d'orénavant il
n'existe plus un seul tourisme mais des
tourismes avec l'itourisme sur le web le
M tourisme sur les mobiles et le
tourisme social sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui plus de 80 % des touristes
prépare leur voyage sur internet que ce
soit dans la préparation ou dans la
réservation
la maîtrise du numérique est devenue
indispensable chose que les
professionnels du tourisme français ont
mis du temps à
comprendre et appliquer faute aussi bien
souvent de ressources nécessaires face à
un tel investissement en cela la
contribution des professionnels du
tourisme en ligne à l'économie du
tourisme en France et sa modernisation
est significative et le sera encore le
rapport présenté par Madame la Députée
Pascale Gott en février 2015 a confirmé
cette observation les hôteliers en
particulier les indépendants et les plus
modestes qui n'ont pas les moyens de
développer eux-mêmes une stratégie
Internet ont recours aux agences de
tourisme en ligne pour atteindre une
clientèle étrangère et palier les
baisses d'activité saisonnière de plus
les services que rendent ces agences
sont un coûte que les hôteliers n'ont
parfois pas la capacité d'endosser
eux-mêmes et ce n'est pas au titre d'un
éventuel gain sur la clause de parité
tarifaire que les petites et moyennes
structures hôtelières pourront se
permettre un tel investissement
aujourd'hui déjà beaucoup de
consommateurs pensent instinctivement
que les prix sont plus élevés sur
internet à cause de la présence d'un
intermédiaire sans clause d'accès au
prix le plus bas les hôtels
proposeraient des tarifs moins
attractifs sur les sites d'agents de
voyage en ligne que ceux qu'il pourrait
proposer directement au consommateurs
devant de simples annuairire les agences
de voyage se désengageraient comme
peut-être les touristes étrangers qui
n'ayant pas accès au meilleur prix
opteraient pour d'autres destinations
les hôteliers finiraient par ne plus
avoir accès à la même qualité de service
et la réputation de la France comme
destination privilégiée des touristes du
monde entier n'en sortirai pas grandi si
les hôteliers ne souffriront assurément
qu'à moyen terme de la disparition de la
clause qui est un élément central des
relations commerciales entre hôtel et
Agen de voyage en ligne les
consommateurs en feront les frais
aussitôt pour ces raisons il semble
opportun de ne pas maintenir tenir dans
le texte de cet article la mention
suivante non obstant la disposition de
la Linéa précédent l'aôutelier conserve
la liberté de consentir au lien tout
Rabé ou avantage tarifaire de quelque
nature que ce soit voilà pour ces débats
dans l'hémicycle sur le projet de loi
croissance et activité que vous
connaissez aussi sous le nom de projet
de loi Macron du nom du ministre de
l'économie vous avez vu le ministre de
l'économie et les sénateurs s'affronté
sur plusieurs articles sur plusieurs
amendements il reste plus de 800
amendements à dis
avant le vote solennel du texte qui est
prévu pour l'instant le 6 mai les
sénateurs avancent encore assez
doucement dans l'examen de ce texte il
risque d'y avoir sans doute encore du
retard vous pouvez voir et revoir cette
séance et toutes les autres en VOD sur
notre site public sa.fr très bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires